ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM. THE
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL. ACOSTA.
AGUIAR-CURRY.
ALLEN.
ARAMBULA.
BAKER.
BERMAN.
BIGELOW.
BLOOM.
BONTA.
BRUNO.
BURKE.
CABALLERO.
CALDERON.
CARILLO.
CERVANTES.
CHAO CHEN.
DAVID CHIU. CHOI.
KANSEN CHU.
COOLEY.
COOPER.
CUNNINGHAM.
DALLEY.
DALY.
EGGMAN.
FLORA.
FONG.
FRASER.
FRIEDMAN.
GALLAGHER IN ORDER GARCIA.
GIPSON.
GLORIA. GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
GRAY.
GRAYSON.
HARPER.
HOLDEN.
IRWIN.
JONES SAWYER.
KALRA.
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KILEY.
LACKEY.
LEVINE.
LIMON.
LOW MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS.
MAYES.
MCCARTY.
MEDINA.
MELENDEZ.
MULLIN.
MURATSUCHI.
THIS AREA.
OBERNOLTE.
O'DONNELL.
PATTERSON.
QUIRK.
QUIRK SILVA.
REYES
RODRIGUEZ
WE SALAS
SANTIAGO.
STEINORTH.
STONE.
BERMAN.
TING.
POPE WELL.
WALDRON.
WEBER.
WOOD. MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
A QUORUM IS PRESENT IN THE
ASSEMBLY.
WE ASK THAT OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER.
AND IN THE GALLERY.
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER.
TODAY'S PRAYER.
WILL BE OFFERED BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SHIRLEY WEBER DOCTOR
WEBER.
LET US PRAY.
FATHER WHEN I VISIT MY FRIEND OF
MANY YEARS.
THE NANA.
THE CHIEF INCOME MOSSY.
UNDER WE ASK ONLY ONE QUESTION.
SISTER SHIRLEY.
HOW ARE THE CHILDREN?
THIS QUESTION SPEAKS TO THE
HEART OF THE LEADER BECAUSE THE
TRUE WORTH OF THE CHIEF.
IT'S HOW WELL THE CHILDREN ARE
FARING.
THIS DEMONSTRATE WHETHER THE
VILLAGE WILL SURVIVE MAINTAIN
ITS TRADITIONS AND VALUES AND
CONTRIBUTE TO THE WELL BEING OF
THE COUNTRY.
THE ROLE OF THE LEADERS TO MAKE
SURE THAT CHILDREN ARE SAFE
PHYSICALLY AND MENTALLY.
FATHER WHO ASKED THIS QUESTION
TODAY.
WE MUST ADMIT THAT ONCE AGAIN WE
HAVE WITNESSED ANOTHER SHOOTING
OF OUR CHILDREN IN OUR SCHOOLS.
NOT AT THE HAND OF FOREIGNERS.
VIOLENCE FROM WITHIN.
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT WE HAVE
SEEN TWENTY SEVEN VIOLENT ACTS
IN OUR SCHOOL.
AND THERE HAS NOT EVEN BEEN
TWENTY SEVEN WEEKS IN THIS YEAR.
IN THE PAST NINE YEARS WE HAVE
WITNESSED TWO HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
EIGHT SCHOOL SHOOTINGS.
THE LARGEST IN THE WORLD.
AND THE SECOND LARGEST IS ONLY
EIGHT SHOOTINGS IN MEXICO.
WE'VE HAD MORE DEATHS IN OUR
SCHOOLS THIS YEAR THAN DEATHS
AMONG THE MEN IN UNIFORM AROUND
THE WORLD.
AND OUR SCHOOLS ARE NOT SUPPOSED
TO BE WAR ZONE.
YET WE CONTINUE LEADERS CONTINUE
TO DEBATE THE ISSUE.
MAKING SURE THAT WHATEVER WE
THINK IS A PROBLEM.
THAT WE ARE NOT THE BLAME.
MEANWHILE AS THE AFRICAN PROVERB
SAYS WHEN TWO ELEPHANTS FIGHT.
IT IS THE GRASS THAT SUFFERS.
OUR CHILDREN.
THE GRASS.
OR THE VICTIMS OF OUR DEBATES
AND ARE IN ACTION.
LET US PRAY THAT WE WILL
SINCERELY ADDRESS THIS ISSUE IN
THE STATE AND NATION. MAKING
SURE THAT THE WELL BEING OF OUR
CHILDREN IS CENTRAL TO OUR
MISSION. AND REFLECTED IN ALL OF
OUR WORK.
IT IS MY PRAYER.
AND ARE PRAYER.
BUT WHEN I RETURN TO COME MOSSY.
SEE THE NANA.
AND HE ASKED THE QUESTION AGAIN.
SISTER SHIRLEY.
HOW ARE THE CHILDREN?
I CAN SAY PROBABLY IN HONESTY.
NANA.
THEY ARE WELL.
A MAN.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WEBER WE ASK
OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS TO
REMAIN STANDING AND JOIN US FOR
THE FLAG SALUTE. PLEASE JOIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN AS
HE LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE MISTER
MANCHAC.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG.
AND TO THE. OF SAN.
WOW IS IS. LIBERTY AND JUSTICE
FOR ALL.
THANK YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL ASSEMBLY CHAMBER
SACRAMENTO MONDAY MAY SEVENTH
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN THE
CINEMATIC SOMEONE PME I'LL TALK
GLORIOUS SOMETHING OR SEMI
DISREGARDING SHE FORGOT SOME OF
THE DESPERATE LOOK AT THE MOVES
READING. THE RULES BECAUSE IT
WASN'T ARATA MOVES AND MISS
WALDRON SECONDS THAT THE READING
OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL BE
DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS OF PETITIONS THERE
ARE NONE.
INTRODUCTION REFERENCE OF BILLS
WILL BE DEFERRED REPORTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS TO
ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE.
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE.
THERE ARE NONE.
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS.
THE ABSENCES FOR THE DAY.
FOR LEGISLATIVE BUSINESS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER EDUARDO GARCIA.
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER ADAM GRAY
FOR PERSONAL BUSINESS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CRISTINA GARCIA. FOR
ILLNESS
ASSEMBLY WOMAN SUSAN EGGMAN
.
MEMBERS A NOTICE THE PRESENCE OF
A FORMER MEMBER OF THIS HOUSE.
THE HONORABLE ALICE AND HUMOR
NOW LUIS WELCOME BACK TO.
FOR
MEMBERS WE ARE PROCEDURAL
MOTIONS.
MR BONTA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR PROCEDURAL MOTION SIR.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE
POINT FIVE.
AND ALLOW ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
CABALLERO KILEY ACOSTA RUBIO AND
STEINORTH TO SPEAK ON AND
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY TODAY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER PLEASE
REMOVE THE FOLLOWING BILL FROM
THE CONSENT CALENDAR AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR ITEM
NUMBER NINETY TWO. AB TWENTY ONE
TWENTY FIVE QUIRK.
THE CLERK WILL KNOW.
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
WAVE JOINT RULE SIXTY TWO A THE
FILE NOTICE REQUIREMENT TO ALLOW
THE FOLLOWING COMMITTEES TO
MEET.
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE TEST
SET AB TWENTY EIGHTY SEVEN
WALDRON AND AB TWO SIX SIX SEVEN
COOLEY FOR WEDNESDAY MAY TWENTY
THIRD AT NINE AM IN ROOM A FORTY
TWO OH TWO. AND THE SELECT
COMMITTEE ON DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
TO HOLD A HEARING ON THURSDAY
MAY TWENTY FOURTH AT ONE THIRTY
PM. IN ROOM FOUR FORTY SEVEN.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER
HAVE GUESTS WITH US IN THE
ASSEMBLY CHAMBER.
THAT WE WOULD LIKE TO RECOGNIZE.
MR GRACE AND I BELIEVE YOU HAVE
GUESTS
IN THE CHAMBER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
I'M HAPPY TO INTRODUCE KEVIN
REILLY AND CHRIS OWENS A VALLEJO
ADMIRALS BASEBALL TEAM. THEY'RE
WITH US TODAY UP IN THE GALLERY.
THE BAY AREA IS HOME TO MANY
GREAT SPORTS TEAMS IN THE
VALLEJO ADMIRALS BASEBALL TEAM
IS ONE OF A.
HAVING WON THE TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN PACIFIC ASSOCIATION OF
PROFESSIONAL BASEBALL CLUBS
CHAMPIONSHIP JUST THIS PAST
FALL.
KEVIN AND CHRIS HAVE EVEN
BROUGHT THE CHAMPIONSHIP TROPHY
HELD UP HIGH ABOVE HIS HEAD
RIGHT NOW UP IN THE GALLERY.
THEY STRUGGLED THROUGH THE FIRST
HALF OF THE SEASON FINDING
THEMSELVES LOOKING UP IN THE
STANDINGS IN THE VALLEJO
ADMIRALS FOUNDER GREG. AND ONE
TWENTY FIVE FOR THE NEXT THIRTY
FOUR GAMES TO CLOSE OUT THE
SEASON.
DURING THE CHAMPIONSHIP GAME
CENTERFIELDER TILLMAN BICU
BATTED IN THREE RUNS AND AFTER
THE GAME HE SAID YOU WIN SOME.
YOU LOSE SOME YOU STAY
RELENTLESS YOU KEEP GOING AND
KEEP PUSHING FORWARD THE VALLEJO
ADMIRALS KEPT PUSHING FORWARD
ALL THE WAY FROM UNDERDOGS TO
LEAGUE CHAMPIONS MEMBERS PLEASE
JOIN IN CONGRATULATING ME.
WITH THE VALLEJO ADMIRALS
WHO ARE WITH US TODAY
.
AND MS.
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
YOU HAVE SPECIAL GUESTS IN THE
CHAMBER TODAY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FROM YOUR DESK.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
IN THE GALLERY TODAY.
ARE YOU SEE LA STUDENT ATHLETES
OLYMPIANS TWINS AND ASSISTANT
COACHES FROM THE MEN'S WATER
POLO TEAM THE WOMEN'S GYMNASTICS
TEAM AND THE WOMEN'S BEACH
VOLLEYBALL TEAM. ALL ONE NC A A
CHAMPIONSHIPS THIS YEAR.
AND MR GRAYSON WE TO HAVE A
TROPHY TO SHOW IN THE GALLEY.
UCLA STUDENT ATHLETES HAVE AN
OUTSTANDING RECORD OF WINNING IN
CA A CHAMPION.
THESE THREE TEAMS BROUGHT THE
TOTAL UP TO ONE HUNDRED AND
SIXTEEN MAKING UCLA TIED IN
FIRST PLACE FOR THE MOST TITLES
OF ANY IN C. A. A DIVISION ONE
SCHOOL.
ONE OF THE REASONS WHY WE FIGHT
SO HARD TO ADEQUATELY SUPPORT
OUR UC SYSTEM IS BECAUSE THEY
HAVE THE POTENTIAL TO GENERATE
JAMS LIKE THESE ATHLETES AND
COACHES. THAT WE RECOGNIZE
TODAY.
I THINK EACH OF YOU FOR YOUR
HARD WORK AND DEDICATION AS
ATHLETES AND AS STUDENTS AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO REPRESENTING
THIS AMAZING UNIVERSITY IN THE
ASSEMBLY.
PLEASE STOP BY MEMBERS TO
CONGRATULATE OUR GUESTS AT THEIR
RECEPTION TODAY FROM THREE TO
FOUR PM IN ROOM ONE TWENTY FIVE.
MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN ME IN
CONGRATULATING THESE TEAMS FOR
THEIR ACCOMPLISHMENTS THIS YEAR.
THANK YOU
AND MR LEVINE.
YOU HAVE GUESTS IN THE CHAMBER
TODAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I'M
DELIGHTED STATUS HAVE ONCE WHAT
GOT TO SCHOOLS THAT ARE VISITING
ME I'VE GOT.
THE FIFTH GRADE FROM SAINT
HILLARY SCHOOL IN TIMBER ON AS
WELL AS SENIORS FROM TERRA LINDA
HIGH SCHOOL IN SAN RAFAEL.
WELCOME STUDENTS IT'S SO GREAT
TO HAVE YOU HERE TODAY WITH US
THANK YOU
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE TO
SECOND READING.
THE CLERK WILL READ. SOME PEOPLE
TWENTY SEVEN FORTY SIX TWENTY
THIRTY SIX AND ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY SIX THREE WITH
AMENDMENTS.
ALL BILLS HAVE BEEN DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE.
ON RECONSIDERATION ITEM SIX.
THROUGH ELEVEN.
ARE TO BE CONTINUED.
WE'RE MOVING TO THE ASSEMBLY
THIRD READING FILE FILE ITEMS.
TWELVE AND THIRTEEN PASS AND
RETAIN.
FILE ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN.
IS AB TWENTY ONE EIGHTY FIVE BY
MISTER DAVID CHIU THE CLERK WILL
READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE EIGHTY
FIVE BY SOME MEMBER DAVID CHIU
ACCOLADE A CIVIL ACTIONS.
MISTER CHIU YOU MAY OPEN THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER COLLEAGUES AB
TWENTY ONE EIGHTY FIVE WOULD
ALLOW AN INDIVIDUAL LITIGATION
TO PROCEED. ANONYMOUSLY AFTER
COURT CONSIDERS A NUMBER OF
RELEVANT FACTORS.
THERE MANY CIRCUMSTANCES UNDER
WHICH THIS MAY BE NECESSARY SUCH
AS WHEN THERE'S A RISK OF
RETALIATORY HARM. OR DURING THIS
TIME IN HISTORY WHEN A PLAINTIFF
LEGITIMATELY FEARS THE REVEALING
ONE'S IDENTITY COULD SUBJECT HER
TO DEPORTATION.
UNLIKE OTHER STATES THAT HAVE
STANDARDS FOR PLAINTIFFS TO
PURSUE LITIGATION WITH THE
PSEUDONYM. OUR STATE DOES NOT
HAVE SUCH A STANDARD OR BILL
WOULD ALLOW AN INDIVIDUAL TO
PROCEED ANONYMOUSLY IN
LITIGATION AND REQUIRE COURTS TO
CONSIDER A VARIETY RELEVANT
FACTORS. A PARTY COULD CHALLENGE
THE USE OF A PSEUDONYM AND OF A
COURT ORDERS AN ANONYMOUS
LITIGANT TO BE IDENTIFIED THAT
PARTY COULD CHOOSE TO DISMISS
THE CLAIMS WITHOUT PREJUDICE.
I APPRECIATE THE BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT INNOCENT WITHOUT RESPECT
WE ASK FOR MY BOAT.
THINK WAS CHU SEEING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
CLERK IN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE THE ROLE AND TALLIED ABOUT
ICE FIFTY KNOWS FIVE.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEMS FIFTEEN AND SIXTEEN
PASS RETAIN.
WHERE FILE ITEM SEVENTEEN?
AB TWENTY NINE FIFTY FIVE
CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY NINE FIFTY
FIVE BY SO MEMBER BEREAVEMENT
ACRYLATE THE TRAFFIC.
MS FRIEDMAN YOU MAY OPEN THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE TO
PRESENT A DISTRICT BILL AB
TWENTY NINE FIFTY FIVE AS
AMENDED ON THE FLOOR ON THURSDAY
MAY SEVENTEENTH. AND AN EFFORT
TO MAINTAIN THE WESTERN HERITAGE
OF THE RANCHO AREA THAT EXTENDS
FROM THE RIVERSIDE RANCHO AREA
IN GLENDALE TO THE RANCHO MASTER
PLAN IN BURBANK.
THIS BILL RECEIVED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT IN THE ASSEMBLY
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE AND
WITH THE AMENDMENTS NOW LEGALLY
DEFINED AREA KNOWN AS THE RANCHO
MASTER PLAN.
THIS AREA IS CONSTANTLY AT RISK
OF SPEED INCREASES DESPITE BEING
AN EQUESTRIAN ZONE.
AS THE HORSE OWNER MYSELF WHO'S
WRITTEN FOR YEARS IN THIS AREA
I'VE SEEN THE INCREASED SPEED
AND TRAFFIC IN AN AREA THAT'S
BOUND BY TO FREEWAYS. AND WHICH
IS OFTEN A ROUTE TAKEN BY PEOPLE
WHO DON'T KNOW THAT THEIR
PRESENCE OF COURSES CAN BE
EXPECTED IN THE AREA.
THE RANCHO AREA HAS ROUGHLY
SEVENTY THOUSAND RESIDENTS WITH
ABOUT THIRTY PERCENT OWNING
HORSES IN THE AREA. THE AREA HAS
BEEN AN EQUESTRIAN HAVEN RIGHT
IN THE HEART OF LOS ANGELES
SINCE THE NINETEEN THIRTIES.
AB TWENTY NINE FIFTY FIVE AS
AMENDED ALLOWS THIS AREA TO
INCORPORATE EQUESTRIAN SAFETY
AND TO HOW TRAFFIC ENGINEERING
STUDIES ARE CONDUCTED ONLY IN
THIS TO FIND AREA.
THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE HAS
ALLOWED THE CITIES OF NORCO AND
THE DEVELOPMENT IN ORANGE.
ORANGE PARK ACTS ACRES TO
CONSIDER EQUESTRIAN SAFETY AND
HOW THEY CONDUCT SPEED SURVEYS
THESE EFFORTS ARE TO KEEP.
HORSES SAFE IN URBAN SETTINGS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE AND ASK YOU TO SAVE YOUR
NAY IS FOR THE HORSES.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE ITEM.
MEMBERS SETTLE DOWN.
CLARK LA.
CLICK LIBERAL.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
ZARA VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
OUT OF THOSE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROUND TIED ABOUT I SIXTY
FOUR NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES
FILE ITEM EIGHTEEN PASS RETAIN.
WE ARE FILE ITEM NINETEEN AB
TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY EIGHT BY
MISTER TAME CORPORATE. ASSEMBLY
WILL TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY EIGHT
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER TAKEN OTHERS
AN ACCOLADE FIREARMS MISTER
TECH.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER ARE.
OUR COLLEAGUE FROM SAN DIEGO
GAVE AN INCREDIBLY ELOQUENT.
PRAYER.
THIS MORNING WHICH.
LAYS THE.
THE ARGUMENT FOR AB TWENTY EIGHT
EIGHTY EIGHT.
THIS IS A BILL THAT I
INTRODUCED IN TWENTY SIXTEEN
WHOSE EXPANSION OF WHAT SENATOR
SKINNER ON. PASSED
AND GOT SIGNED BY THE GOVERNOR
TO EXPAND THE GUN VIOLENCE
RESTRAINING WERE THE GOOD BOUNCE
RESTRAINING ORDERS A VERY SIMPLE
IDEA. THAT.
MODELED AFTER DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
RESTRAINING ORDERS THAT YOU CAN
GO TO COURT. IF YOU BELIEVE
SOMEONE IS A DANGER SHOULD NOT
HAVE A GUN IT ALLOWS PEOPLE
CURRENTLY IN LAW.
THAT IF YOU'RE A FAMILY MEMBER
AND IF YOU ARE A CURRENT LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICIAL. TO BE ABLE
TO GO TO COURT AND
HOW THAT HAPPENED.
WELL UNFORTUNATELY SENSE THEN.
FIFTEEN NUMEROUS SHOOTINGS OCCUR
LIKE THE ONE ON FRIDAY
UNFORTUNATELY.
SCHOOLS
PEOPLE WHO ARE CLEARLY KNEW THAT
A STUDENT WAS POTENTIALLY A
PERSON WHO I SHOULDN'T HAVE A
GUN I SHOULD HAVE ACCESS TO A
GUN WILL BE ABLE TO HELP WE SAW
THAT KIND OF SITUATION.
THAT POTENTIALLY COULD HAPPEN
TO PARKLAND IN PARK LAND WE HAD
EIGHT INDIVIDUAL WHO CLEARLY OF
THE PRINCIPAL KNEW THE TEACHERS
KNEW THEY COULD HAVE USED THIS
TYPE. OF.
GOING BONTA STRAINING ORDER WE
ALSO SEE IT INSTANCES AROUND
COWORKERS SO THAT'S WHY. WE WANT
TO HAVE THE INTENTION OF
EXPANDING IT TO CO WORKERS AND
EMPLOYERS AS WELL AS PEOPLE ARE
SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS TEACHERS.
FACULTY PROFESSORS
WE DID TAKE OUT FROM TWENTY
SIXTEEN MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS. NOBLE OF MENTAL
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS DID NOT
WANT TO BE INCLUDED SO WE TOOK
THEM OUT WE HEARD THEM.
OUR THIS BILL DID PASS
LEGISLATURE TO GET VETOED FROM
THE GOVERNOR OF MY HOPE IS THAT
WE CAN AGAIN FLORIDA TO THE
GOVERNOR BELIEVE THE TIMES ARE
DIFFERENT. THAN THE MODE THE
MOOD IS DIFFERENT.
WE NOW HAVE AFTER TWO YEARS
ABOUT TWO HUNDRED OF THESE
RESTRAINING ORDERS ALMOST ALL OF
THEM ENTIRELY. OUR HOUSE FOR BY
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND WE FEEL THAT
THAT'S AN EFFECTIVE TOOL TO GET
GUNS OUT OF THE HANDS OF THE
WRONG PEOPLE. ALL I CONTINUE TO
HAVE.
GOOD DISCUSSIONS WITH.
PART WITH PARTY MEMBERS WERE
PASSED THE ISLAND WITH THE DO
HOPE THAT WE CAN CONTINUE TO
HAVE THAT DISCUSSION THE SECOND
HOUSE TO MAKE THIS AN EVEN
STRONGER BILL AND EVEN A BETTER
BILL. I MEAN REALLY WOULD LIKE
TO HAVE THE.
BIPARTISAN PATH FOR WITH THIS
BILL.
BUT TODAY AGAIN ON THE HEELS OF
A BUT UNFORTUNATELY HAPPENED IN
TEXAS. I REALLY DO ASK THAT WE
DON'T JUST SEND THOUGHTS AND
PRAYERS BUT THAT WE DO. SOME
ACTION BE SENSIBLE ACTION TO OUR
STUDENTS TO FAMILIES WHO REALLY
ARE SCRATCHING THEIR HEADS AND
WONDERING WHAT WE CAN DO.
TO STEM THE VIOLENCE IN OUR
SCHOOLS AND WITHOUT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR VOTE ON AB
TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY.
THANK EXTINGUISHER GIPSON YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS ARE RISE AND
SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
EIGHT EIGHTY EIGHT I THINK THE
AUTHOR FROM SAN FRANCISCO.
BRINGING IS A GOOD OF MEASURE
BEFORE THIS BODY WITHOUT BEING
REDUNDANT I THINK THAT HE SUMMED
IT UP AND MY TALK POINTS
REFLECTS SOME OF THINGS THAT HE
SAID ALSO. DOCTOR WEBER WITH HER
ELOQUENCE IN HER PRAYER I WOULD
SAY THAT WE REMEMBER.
THE SHOOTER THE SHOOTING THAT
TOOK PLACE AT DOUGLASS HIGH
SCHOOL. OF IN PARKLAND FLORIDA
LAST FEBRUARY SEVENTEEN.
YOUNG PEOPLE WERE KILLED.
OF THIS BILL IF IT WAS AN ACT OF
CERTAINLY WILL PROVIDE AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR A THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO KNOW INDIVIDUAL.
WHO MAY BE SUFFERING FROM IT A
MENTAL ILLNESS OR SOMETHING OF
THAT NATURE TO GET THE KIND OF
HELP? BY PROVIDING INFORMATION
SO THAT A RESTRAINING ORDER
COULD IN FACT BE AFFECTED SO
THIS INDIVIDUAL WOULD NOT HAVE
ACCESS TO GUNS I THINK IT MAKES
SENSE AND CERTAINLY. I ENCOURAGE
ALL OF MY COLLEAGUES TO SUPPORT
THIS WOULD AYE VOTE.
NAMES GIPSON ISRAEL'S YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS ARE TO RISE IS A JOINT
AUTHORED AB TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY
EIGHT TO URGE YOUR SUPPORT.
WE SEE THE PLAYING. WITH SOON A
PLAY OUT OVER AND OVER IN OUR
NATION.
A PERSON WITH SEVERE MENTAL
PROBLEMS IT GETS ACCESS TO GUNS
AND TARGETS THE MOST INNOCENT
AMONG US.
AS WE'VE JUST WITNESSED LAST
FRIDAY THE HORRIBLE EVENTS OF
SANTA FE HIGH SCHOOL IN TEXAS.
A REPEAT OF A HORROR WE SEEM TO
SEE ALMOST WEEKLY.
IT'S HORRIFYING TRAGEDIES ALL
SEEM TO HAVE THE SAME SET OF
CIRCUMSTANCES.
GUNS IN THE HANDS OF THOSE THAT
CLEARLY SHOULD NOT HAVE THEM.
AFTER THESE TRAGEDIES THE
STORIES ALWAYS EMERGE THAT THE
PERPETRATOR LEFT CLUES IN SOME
CASES CLEAR INTENT.
AS TO WHAT THEY PLANNED TO DO.
NEIGHBORS FRIENDS AND RELATIVES
STEP FORWARD WITH ACCOUNTS OF
BIZARRE BEHAVIOR ON THE PART OF
THE SHOOTER.
CLEARLY REVEALING WHAT THEY
SHOULD HAVE THAT THEY SHOULD
HAVE WOULD NOT HAVE HAD. ACCESS
TO GUNS.
WE OFTEN DEBATE THE EXTENT OF
THE SECOND AMENDMENT ON THIS
FLOOR BUT THIS BILL DOESN'T
INTERFERE WITH THE LEGAL RIGHT
TO OWN GUNS.
AB TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY EIGHT IS
A COMMONSENSE EXPANSION OF OUR
EXISTING GUN VIOLENCE
RESTRAINING ORDER LAW. THAT WE
WILL ALLOW THOSE MOST OFTEN IN
THE POSITION TO IDENTIFY THAT A
PERSON IS A DANGER TO THEMSELVES
OR OTHERS TO REQUEST A GUN
VIOLENCE RESTRAINING ORDER.
CANNOT REMAIN SILENT WE MUST DO
EVERYTHING IN OUR POWER TO
PREVENT THESE EVENTS FROM TAKING
PLACE WHETHER BE INCREASING THE
USE OF THESE GUN VIOLENCE
RESTRAINING ORDERS. TO
INCREASING ACCESS SOME FUNDING
TO EARLY INTERVENTION FOR MENTAL
HEALTH CARE SERVICES.
WHEN WE REACHED THE POINT IN OUR
U. S. HISTORY WERE MORE CHILDREN
THE BEEN KILLED AND SCHOOL
SHOOTINGS THEN U. S. SERVICE
PERSONNEL IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN. WE'VE REACHED A CRISIS
THAT MUST BE ADDRESSED.
AND I KNOW WE CAN DO SOMETHING.
NO CHILD SHOULD HAVE TO BE
WORRIED THAT WHEN THEY GO TO
SCHOOL IN THE MORNING THAT THEY
MAY BE ENTERING A WAR ZONE.
I WANT NEXT YEAR WHEN MY.
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN DIEGO GOES TO
SEE HER NANA AND IS THE HOUSE
TOWARD THE CHILDREN I WANT HER
TO BE ABLE TO SAY.
THAT THEY ARE FINE.
I THANK THE MEMBER FROM SAN
FRANCISCO FOR HIS TIRELESS
EFFORTS ON THIS BILL AND I URGE
YOUR AYE VOTE TODAY.
NAMES RISK.
MR MERCHANT SHE
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MEMBERS ENOUGH IS ENOUGH.
HOW MANY MORE IS SCHOOL
SHOOTINGS DO WE NEED TO SEE
BEFORE WE START PASSING COMMON
SENSE GUN SAFETY LAWS?
I'VE ALWAYS RESPECTED THE RIGHT
OF LAW ABIDING CITIZENS TO OWN.
AND YOU AND POSSESS
GUNS RESPONSIBLY BUT CLEARLY. AS
WE EVERY NEW SHOOTING.
WE'RE BEING REMINDED THAT WE
HAVE SO MUCH MORE WORK TO DO.
AS A DAD WITH A DAUGHTER IN A
PUBLIC SCHOOL.
I'M ESPECIALLY IN SUPPORT OF THE
PROVISION OF THIS BILL THAT
ALLOWS FOR SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
WE'VE SEEN AS A. AS A MY
COLLEAGUE MS RAISE THEY
INDICATED THAT THE STUDENTS
KNOW.
WHO THE PROBLEM STUDENTS ARE?
THE EMPLOYEES KNOW WHO THE
PROBLEM STUDENTS ARE. WE NEED TO
EMPOWER THEM GIVEN THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO BE ABLE TO FILE
FOR THESE GUN RESTRAINING ORDERS
SO THAT WE CAN TAKE AWAY THE
GUNS FROM THE MENTALLY ILL AND
THOSE WHO PRESENT DANGER TO
THEMSELVES AND OTHERS. SO THAT
WE CAN FIGHT.
COMMON SENSE GUN SAFETY AND OUR
SCHOOLS AYE ASTRAEA AYE VOTE.
MISS MELENDEZ YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
I I FIRST WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR OF THE BILL FOR COMING TO
MY OFFICE IN SPEAKING WITH ME.
WE TRIED VERY HARD TO COME TO
SOME SORT OF AGREEMENT OF HOW TO
MAKE THIS BILL SOMETHING THAT I
COULD SUPPORT AS WELL
UNFORTUNATELY WE WEREN'T ABLE TO
GET THERE. BUT I DO APPRECIATE
THE ATTEMPT.
IS PROBABLY THE FIRST TIME
YOU'VE EVER SAT NAPS WITH THE
NRA SO YOU KNOW SPURS FOR
EVERYTHING.
I.
I DON'T HAVE ANY ISSUE WITH THIS
BILL WERE IT NOT FOR THE FACT.
THAT IT IS EXPERTS HAY IN HERE
MEANING THAT.
YOUR WEAPONS COULD BE TAKEN AWAY
A JUDGE COULD DECIDE THAT
WITHOUT YOU EVEN BEING THERE TO
SHARE YOUR SIDE OF THE STORY. ON
THAT THAT COULD TAKE TWENTY ONE
DAYS FREE TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT.
AND THAT IS CONCERNING TO ME.
THE COMMENTS THAT WERE MADE
ABOUT THE TRAGEDIES THAT HAVE
TAKEN PLACE TO SCHOOL SHOOTINGS
IN PARTICULAR.
.
I THINK WE ALL AGREE THAT IT'S
HORRIFIC.
BUT THIS BILL.
WOULDN'T HAVE PREVENTED THAT.
WHEN YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT MINERS
PARTICULARLY IN THE LAST SCHOOL
SHOOTING THAT YOUNG MAN NOT ONLY
DID HE TAKE WEAPONS THAT WERE
NOT HIS OWN WERE NOT REGISTERED
TO HIM.
HE WASN'T EVEN OLD ENOUGH TO
HAVE THEM.
SEOUL THIS TYPE OF BILL I JUST I
THINK IT'S INAPPROPRIATE TO USE.
THAT SCENARIO AS THE REASON FOR
THIS BILL.
.
THIS
SAME EXACT BILL WAS VETOED BY
THE GOVERNOR LAST YEAR.
BECAUSE A GUN VIOLENCE
RESTRAINING ORDER HAD ALREADY
BEEN SIGNED BY HIM ONE THAT I
THINK WAS.
.
MORE NARROW.
AND SO THIS BILL CAME FORWARD
AGAIN LAST YEAR THE GOVERNOR
SAID IT WAS TOO SOON TO EXTEND
IT. I'M WITH WHICH I AGREE.
I HOPE THAT WE CAN GET TO THE
POINT WHERE WE CAN COLLABORATE
AND PERHAPS DO A BILL TOGETHER.
BECAUSE
I DON'T THINK THERE'S A PERSON
IN THIS ROOM WHO DOESN'T.
WANT TO DO SOMETHING.
FIND A WAY TO STOP THESE TYPES
OF THINGS FROM HAPPENING.
BUT WHENEVER ANYBODY SAYS WE
HAVE TO DO SOMETHING THAT
USUALLY MEANS THEY DON'T KNOW
WHAT TO DO.
AND SO THEY END UP DOING
WHATEVER.
COMES TO MIND AND SEEMS LIKE IT
MIGHT BE A GOOD IDEA IN THIS
PARTICULAR CASE I'M NOT
CONVINCED THAT IT IS.
SO WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR NO VOTE.
MISTER GALLAGHER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER IS
MEMBERS.
THIS ISSUE THAT HITS VERY CLOSE
TO HOME FOR ME.
YOU KNOW.
IN THE COMMUNITY OF RANCHO TO
HEMA.
WE HAD A SIMILAR. INCIDENT
WHERE LIKELY NO STUDENTS WERE
KILLED BUT WE HAD A GUN THEN. GO
THROUGH A NEIGHBORHOOD SHOOTING
UP HIS FRIENDS AND NEIGHBORS.
AND THEN GOING ON TO A SCHOOL
CAMPUS.
RAMMING THE FENCE DOWN.
AND THEY GO IN THERE AND
ACTUALLY SHOOTING IN THE
CLASSROOMS.
AND YOU ABOUT FOR THE HERO WAS A
AM.
OF TEACHERS AND STAFF THERE
THAT DAY THAT COULD HAVE BEEN
MUCH MORE.
DIRE SITUATION I GREW UP.
NOW.
IN A SMALL COMMUNITY NOT VERY
HARD FROM NOT VERY FAR FROM
LENDERS TIES SCHOOL WHICH WAS
ONE OF THE.
VERY FIRST SCHOOL SHOOTINGS IN
CALIFORNIA HISTORY I MEMBER
THAT.
YOU THE FEAR ASSOCIATED WITH
THAT HAD.
FRIENDS. YOU KNOW WHOSE FAMILY
HAD GONE THROUGH THAT.
AND NOBODY WANTS TO EVER BE IN
THAT SITUATION I THINK WE ALL I
FOR ONE BELIEVE WE DO NEED TO
TAKE ACTION.
TO HELP ENSURE THAT THESE
THINGS DON'T HAPPEN.
TO DO WHAT WE CAN TO HELP
PREVENT THEM FROM HAPPENING.
BUT ONE CONCERN I HAVE IS HOW
THIS IS BEING TEED UP TODAY AS
IS THIS IS THE.
THIS IS A SOLUTION TO THAT.
AND THAT.
.
ALMOST SAID HEY IF YOU'RE NOT
DOWN WITH THIS IF YOU'RE NOT
WILLING TO SUPPORT THIS
PARTICULAR POLICY MEASURE THAT
YOU'RE NOT WELL INTO.
TO TAKE ACTION THERE'S MANY
THINGS WE CAN DO.
RESTRAINING ORDERS ARE AN
EFFECTIVE TOOL.
THEY ARE AN EFFECTIVE TOOL.
WHEN THEY'RE ENFORCED.
IN THE CASE OF GRANTED TO HIM OF
THE GOVERNMENT HAD A RESTRAINING
ORDER AGAINST HIM BECAUSE HE HAD
ACTUALLY FIRED ON HIS NEIGHBORS.
AND SO THROUGH THE COURT SYSTEM
ALREADY.
BECAUSE OF THAT INCIDENT. THE DA
WAS ABLE TO GET A RESTRAINING
ORDER AGAINST HIM.
HE TURNED IN ONE HANDGUN.
TO THE LOCAL SHERIFF.
BUT GUESS WHAT IN THE MEANTIME
IN THE EIGHT MONTHS SINCE HE HAD
THAT RESTRAINING ORDER.
HE GOT OTHER GUNS E ACTUALLY
BUILT HIS OWN GUN.
ANY HAD OTHER GUNS HE DID TURN
IT AND NOBODY BOTHERED TO
ACTUALLY GO AND ENFORCE A
RESTRAINING ORDER SO LET'S NOT.
STANDARD SALE IF WE PASS THIS
BILL WE'RE GONNA STOP THE SEAS
BECAUSE THERE'S ONE THING WE
HAVEN'T BEEN TALKING ABOUT IS
VERY IMPORTANT YOU HAVE TO
ENFORCE THE RESTRAINING ORDERS.
WE HAVE A PROGRAM.
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE.
RUNS CALLED THE APPS PROGRAM.
DISPOSED TO GO TO INDIVIDUALS
WHO HAVE RESTRAINING ORDERS
AGAINST THEM BECAUSE THEY
COMMITTED CRIMES AGAINST PEOPLE.
BECAUSE THEY HAVE ACTUAL HISTORY
OF DOING VIOLENT THINGS WHO HAVE
SERIOUS MENTAL DISORDERS AND
THEREFORE ON THE PROHIBITED
PERSONS LIST DOJ IS SUPPOSED TO
GO TO THEIR HOMES AND DISARM
THEM.
THEY TAKE THE GUNS AWAY.
THEY HAVEN'T BEEN DOING IT. IN
THIS IS BEEN MENTIONED MANY MANY
TIMES OVER THE YEARS I'VE BEEN
HERE.
THAT WE STILL HAVE THIS HUGE
BACKLOG WITH THE APP'S PROGRAM.
WE GAVE THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS
TO CLEAR THEY STILL HAVEN'T
DONE.
SO WHERE IS THE DEMAND ON
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE ON THESE
REGULATORY AGENCIES WHO ARE
SUPPOSED TO BE DOING THIS JOB OF
GETTING THE GUNS AT A DANGEROUS
PEOPLE.
THE OTHER CONCERN I HAVE WITH
THIS BILLS IT DOES BROADLY
EXPAND THE AMOUNT OF PEOPLE THAT
CAN GO IN AND. AND GET AN EX
PARTE AGAIN EX PARTE MEANS YOU
DON'T GET TO COME IN TO DEFEND
YOURSELF.
YOU DON'T GET TO COME IN AND
TELL THE JUDGE WHY YOU
SHOULDN'T.
HAVE THE SEX AND HOW THIS.
TEMPORARY RESTRAINING ORDER PUT
ON AGAINST YOU YOU SHOULD AT
LEAST HAVE THAT OPPORTUNITY.
M. SUMMER THEY JUST WORKED WITH
YOU THAT DOESN'T KNOW YOU.
I MEAN THAT'S WHY WE MADE IT.
THE PREVIOUS LEGISLATION WAS SAY
A FAMILY MEMBER OR A LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICIAL.
THEY WOULD GET THESE RESTRAINING
ORDER SO WE YOU KNOW WE HAVE TO
THINK ABOUT THAT INTRUSION ON
PEOPLE'S. RIGHTS.
AND WHERE ARE WE GOING TO GET
AFTER THE PEOPLE WHO ACTUALLY
HAVE A HISTORY.
OF COMMITTING CRIMES.
THAT'S A BIG DEFICIT I THINK WE
ALSO NEED I THINK IT'S TIME THAT
WE.
HAVE MORE SECURITY AT OUR SCHOOL
CAMPUSES
AND SOME OF SAID TO ME WELL YOU
KNOW THEY HAD SCHOOL OFFICERS AT
SOME OF THESE CAMPUSES AND IT
DIDN'T STOP ANYTHING WELL.
WE HAD RESTRAINING ORDERS IN
PLACE AND IT DIDN'T STOP.
EVERYONE EITHER SO WHAT THAT
TELLS ME IS THAT THERE'S.
THERE'S A MULTI PRONGED APPROACH
HERE.
IT SHOULDN'T JUST BE ALL ONE
POLICY OBJECTIVE IS THE ONLY WAY
THAT WE CAN COMBAT SCHOOL
VIOLENCE THERE'S MANY DIFFERENT
THINGS WE CAN DO. AND I THINK
WE'RE MISSING THE MUCH DEEPER
QUESTION.
THAT WE STILL DON'T TALK ABOUT.
YEAH WE BAND A CERTAIN GUN. WE
PUT CERTAIN TEMPORARY
RESTRAINING ORDER THING IN PLACE
THIRTY SECONDS MISS HIM TELL
OURSELVES ALWAYS SOLVE THE
PROBLEM. BUT WHY WE ANSWERED
SELF THIS QUESTION
WHY IS IT THAT WE HAVE.
TEENAGE KIDS GROWING UP IN THIS
COUNTRY THAT ACTUALLY THINK.
THE DOT IS A SOLUTION IS TO GO
ON TO A CAMPUS. IT START
SHOOTING THEIR FELLOW
CLASSMATES.
WHAT KIND OF A QUOTE AND WHAT WE
ASK OURSELVES WHAT KIND OF A
CULTURE WHAT HAVE WE DONE?
AS A SOCIETY TO DEHUMANIZE.
AND MAKE IT SO THESE KIDS ARE
ACTUALLY GROWING UP IN THINKING
THAT IT'S OKAY TO GO INTO THESE
THINGS I THINK THERE'S A WHOLE
LOT MORE DEEPER ISSUES.
AT ISSUE HERE IT'S NOT JUST ONE
POLICY.
THAT WE PASS HERE TODAY THAT'S
GOING TO SOLVE IT.
PLEASE DON'T SAY THAT THEIR
CHILDREN'S HAY OUT OF HER.
TIME IS UP.
ASK FOR A NO VOTE ON THIS
MEASURE TODAY THANK YOU.
MISTER PATTERSON YOUR RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU SPEAKER OUR. MEMBERS
ARE QUESTION TO THE AUTHOR.
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
MR TEN IS THE AMERICAN CIVIL
LIBERTIES UNION STILL CURRENTLY
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL.
I BELIEVE SO YES.
THANK YOU UP WITH THAT.
.
I WOULD JUST SUGGEST THAT WHEN
THE NATIONAL RIFLE ASSOCIATION
AND WHEN THE AMERICAN CIVIL
LIBERTIES UNION BOTH ARE OPPOSED
TO SOMETHING.
IT'S PROBABLY SOMETHING WE ARE
TO TAKE A REAL LONG LOOK AT
BEFORE. WE PUSH THE GREEN BUTTON
AND SO GIVEN ALL OF THE OTHER.
COMMENTS A WITH RESPECT TO A.
THE OPPOSITION OF EX PARTE ALL
OF THAT.
MEMBERS ARE WE SHOULD BE PUSHING
THE RED BUTTON ON THIS ONE. ARE.
THIS MEANS A WHOLE LOT MORE
WORK.
AND I WOULD SUGGEST TO MY
FRIENDS ACROSS THE AISLE. THAT
WHEN YOU DO THE WORK AND THE
ACLU COMES OFF ITS OPPOSITION
WELL THEN MAYBE YOU SHOULD BRING
IT BACK.
MISTER HARPER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH A MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS. ARE I TOOL
I AGREE WITH THE CONCERNS ARE ON
CIVIL LIBERTIES ON REGARDS THE
EX PARTE. ARE BUT I ALSO THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT TO PROBABLY DIED
DOWN A LITTLE BIT MORE. ARE ON
THE VAGUE TERM A CO WORKER.
I AND I THINK THAT THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT AND DO YOU NEED
TO BE TIGHTENED UP A BY THE
AUTHOR I THINK IT'S SOMETHING
THAT'S A SUBJECT HIGHLY TO
INTERPRETATION AFFECTED THINK
LATER THIS THEY WILL PROBABLY BE
ARGUING. ALL OUR INDEPENDENT TO
A CONTRACTORS INDEED A CO
WORKERS AYE AND HOW DOES THAT
SITUATION INVOLVE ITSELF. AYE IN
SO I THINK THAT THIS LEGISLATION
NEEDS TO BE A LITTLE BIT MORE
BAKED IF YOU WILL AYE IN ORDER
TO MOVE FORWARD AND SO I URGE A
NO VOTE.
MISTER BLOOM YOUR RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU I I JUST WANTED TO GET
UP AS. A ONE PERSON.
.
ON ON THE FLOOR WHO ACTUALLY HAS
EXPERIENCE OF OBTAINING EX PARTY
ORDERS AND I WANT TO CLEAR THE
AIR ABOUT.
PROCESS BEHIND THEM AYE THEIR
IT. IT'S NOT THE CASE ANNA AND I
SHOULD SAY.
IN ADDRESSING THIS THAT I'VE
ACTUALLY SEEN RESTRAINING ORDERS
AND EX PARTY RESTRAINING ORDERS
WHERE GUNS ARE TAKEN OUT OF THE
HANDS OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
THREATENING DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
AND I'M QUITE CERTAIN IN THOSE
CASES. THAT VIOLENT ACTS WERE
PREVENTED DO THEY WORK ALWAYS NO
OF COURSE NOT THERE IS NO ONE.
WAY THERE ARE A MULTITUDE OF
THINGS THAT WE HAVE TO BE DOING
ON THIS VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE.
BUT WHEN IT COMES TO EX PARTE
ORDERS THERE IS DUE PROCESS IT'S
NOT THAT THERE'S NO DUE PROCESS
BUT WHEN A JUDGE SEES A
SITUATION. WHERE IRREPARABLE
HARM IS THREATENED IN THE
MOMENT?
THEN.
SHOULDN'T WE WANT OUR JUDICIAL
OFFICERS TO HAVE THAT DISCRETION
TO ENTER INTO INTO TO TO.
MAKE IN ORDER.
AND THEN WITHIN A VERY SHORT
PERIOD OF TIME THERE FIRST OF
ALL THERE IS A HEARING.
WHEN THE EX PARTY ORDER HAPPENS
AND THEN THERE IS QUICKLY
FOLLOWING THAT A HEARING WHERE
ALL PARTIES ARE ALLOWED TO COME
IN AND ARGUE THEIR CASE. AND
I'VE SEEN SITUATIONS WHERE
SOMETIMES THE ORDER ENDS VERY
QUICKLY WHEN THE JUDGE HEARS
FROM THE OTHER SIDE.
BUT WE SHOULD ALLOW OUR JUDICIAL
OFFICERS TO HAVE DISCRETION OVER
THIS ISSUE SO THAT IN THOSE
LIMITED NUMBER OF INSTANCES
WHERE A VIOLENT ACT CAN BE
STOPPED.
THIS IS ONE WAY WE CAN DO THAT
ACCOMPLISHED THAT I URGE YOUR
AYE VOTE.
NAMES ONE DOCTOR WEBER.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU.
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
LET ME SAY FIRST OF ALL THAT.
I HAD NO IDEA THAT WAS TO TING
WOULD BRING THIS BILL UP THIS
MORNING.
SO THAT WILL OF THOSE WILL
UNDERSTAND THAT IT WAS A PRAYER
FROM MY HEART.
CONCERNING WHAT WE HAVE FACED IN
THIS COUNTRY.
AND I'M NOT SURE IF WE REALLY
UNDERSTAND WHAT OUR CHILDREN ARE
CONSTANTLY SAYING TO US.
THEY'RE AFRAID TO GO TO SCHOOL.
THE FREEDOM WHAT HAPPENS.
AS A GRANDMOTHER AND.
AFRAID EVERY TIME MY GRAND
CHILDREN GO TO SCHOOL.
AND I KNOW THOSE OF YOU WHO ARE
PARENTS ARE AFRAID ALSO.
AND SURELY THIS IS A AN
EXTREMELY LARGE PROBLEM THAT WE
HAVE TO FACE.
AND WE DIDN'T GET HERE
OVERNIGHT.
WE WILL NOT SOLVE THIS PROBLEM
AND EVERYTHING YOU MENTIONED IS
WHAT WE NEED TO DO.
WE HAVE ISSUES OF MENTAL HEALTH.
WE'RE WE HAVE ISSUES OF VALUES.
WE HAVE HATRED THAT PEOPLE
PROMOTE ON TELEVISION THAT COMES
EVEN OUT OF OUR ELECTED
OFFICIALS.
WE HAVE FOLKS WHO DISLIKE OF THE
PEOPLE AND IF WE THINK THAT THAT
DOES NOT IMPACT THE CHILDREN. IN
OUR HOMES AND OUR COMMUNITIES WE
ARE DELUSIONAL.
EVERYTHING IS HURTING OUR
CHILDREN RIGHT NOW.
AND THE PAIN THEY FEEL WE SHOULD
FEEL.
AND SO WHEN WE ARE FACED WITH AN
ISSUE LIKE THIS.
IT IS A SMALL ISSUE IN MANY WAYS
BUT COULD HAVE PROFOUND IMPACT.
IN A COMMUNITY.
IF WE PREVENT ONE INCIDENT FROM
HAPPENING.
WE CANNOT ALLOW THIS TO BECOME
THE NORM.
I DON'T WANT THIS TO BE THE NORM
IN MY CHILDREN'S LIVES AND MY
GRANDCHILDREN'S LIVES WHAT WE
HAVE TO ARM OUR SCHOOLS AND
CREATE BARRIERS AT OUR SCHOOL
AND MAKE THEM LIKE ARMED CAMPS
WHERE KIDS GO TO SCHOOL.
WE PRIDE OURSELVES AS BEING A
CIVILIZED NATION.
AND MOST OF US CAN REFLECT BACK
UPON WHEN WE WERE IN SCHOOL THAT
IS A SAFE PLACE.
THOSE THINGS ARE THE SAFE PLACES
WE GO.
AND SO WHETHER YOU VOTE FOR THIS
AND I HOPE YOU WILL.
BECAUSE THIS IS NOT THE ANSWER
ONLY.
THIS IS ONE OF THE EFFORTS TO
BEGIN TO WRESTLE WITH THIS VERY
DIFFICULT PROBLEM THAT WE FACE.
AND WE CANNOT KEEP WAITING FOR
THE PERFECT.
THING TO HAPPEN IN THEIR FULL
VOICE THE GOOD THAT IS THERE.
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO HAVE A
LOT OF CONVERSATIONS AND A LOT
OF DISCUSSIONS IN A LOT OF
LEGISLATION. ADDED MAY
INCONVENIENCE SOME OF US IN
TERMS OF WHAT WE WANT IN OUR
LIVES.
BUT WE HAVE TO DO IT FOR THE
GREATER GOOD.
AND I SAY THIS BECAUSE AS I
THINK ABOUT THE CONVERSATIONS
THAT WERE HAVING.
REMEMBER WHAT I SAID WHEN THE
ELEPHANTS FIGHT.
THE BIG WARRIORS THE DEMOCRATS
THE REPUBLICANS THE PRO NRA THE
ANTI IN OUR A THAT THIS THAT
THAT AND WE CAN HAVE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS AND OUR CHILDREN
ARE BENEATH THE ELEPHANTS AS WE
STOP AT EACH OTHER.
AND THERE AND WE ARE LOSING THEM
EVERY DAY.
I WANT TO CHALLENGE YOU TO THINK
ABOUT WHAT YOU'RE VOTING ON.
I'M VOTING FOR THIS BILL BECAUSE
IT'S NOT THE ANSWER. BUT IS ONE
OF THE PIECES IN THE PUZZLE.
THAT WE HAVE TO FIGURE OUT.
AND IF YOU DON'T VOTE FOR.
I HOPE YOU COME BACK TO WORK TO
FIND A SOLUTION TO THIS PROBLEM.
BECAUSE AS A NATION WE CANNOT
TOLERATE A SHOOTING IN OUR
SCHOOLS AE SOME GUN VIOLENCE IN
OUR SCHOOLS. EVERY WEEK.
IT IS UNACCEPTABLE TO ME AND IT
SHOULD BE UNACCEPTABLE TO YOU I
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY EIGHT EIGHT.
ALL DEBATE AND DISCUSSION HAVING
CEASED MISTER TING YOU MAY
CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER FIRST
LET ME JUST THINK.
ALL OF MY COLLEAGUES I YOU KNOW
WE'VE HEARD.
MANY PIECES OF LEGISLATION.
REGARDING GUNS AND FIREARMS AND
I WOULD SAY I JUST WANT TO THANK
EVERYBODY FOR AN INCREDIBLY HOT
RESPECTFUL DISCUSSION I THINK
THAT THAT.
TO ME IS A SIGN OF PROGRESS AT
TIMES.
WHERE?
WE ARE STRUGGLING TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT THE ANSWER IS AND AGAIN
THIS BILL ISN'T.
THE ONLY ANSWER.
BUT AS MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN
DIEGO SAID IT'S A PIECE OF THE
PUZZLE.
AND WHAT WE ALL NEED TO DO IS
TRY OUR BEST I KNOW WE ARE
WORKING HARD EVERY SINGLE DAY.
FIGURE OUT WHAT ARE THOSE
DIFFERENT PIECES.
PUZZLE.
TO MAKE.
STREETS SAFER TO MAKE OUR
SCHOOLS SAFER TO MAKE OUR.
WORKPLACES SAFER.
THIS STRUCK ME THE MOST WHEN.
I WAS TALKING TO MY DAUGHTER WAS
IN FIFTH GRADE.
AND.
PROBABLY LIKE MANY PARENTS
ESPECIALLY THOSE WHICH WERE BUSY
WE DON'T GET THAT MUCH TIME TO
TALK TO MY KIDS SO.
I GET TO TALK TO MY DAUGHTER
PRIMARILY WHEN A DRIVER TO
SCHOOL.
A WE GOT AN EMAIL AFTER THE PARK
WHEN SHOOTING FROM OUR FIFTH
GRADE TEACHER.
WHO SAYS DIDN'T REALLY WANT TO
TALK ABOUT?
THIS SUBJECT BUT DIDN'T REALLY
KNOW.
WHAT ELSE?
COULD DO OR HE FELT IT WAS
IRRESPONSIBLE TO NOT TO.
SO HE.
WHEN AND TALKED TO MY DAUGHTERS
FIFTH GRADE CLASS.
RIGHT THIS IS A FIFTH GRADE
CLASS.
ABOUT WHAT.
THEY MAY HAVE TO DO.
IF THERE WAS A SHOULD.
IF THERE WAS AN ACTIVE SHOOTER.
ON SCHOOL.
THAT SHOULD SOME THAT SHOULD BE
SOMETHING THAT NO.
GREATER.
NO TWELFTH GRADER.
NO KINDERGARTNERS.
SHOULD EVER HAVE TO HEAR FROM
THEIR TEETH.
WE BUT HE WAS DOING IT TO BE
RESPONSIBLE AND TO NOT HAVE A
POLITICAL DISCUSSION BUT FRANKLY
WHAT TO DO.
PROTECT YOURSELF.
SO I I AM VERY OWN.
RESPECTFUL ABOUT FOLKS HAVE
DIFFERENCES HAVE CONCERNS.
I HAVE PLAYED TO STAND BIRD JUST
TO ECHO MY COLLECTION SAN
DIEGO'S. PROMISED AND THEN COME
BACK WITH. WHAT THE OTHER POLICY
ALTERNATIVES ARE?
LET'S TALK ABOUT WHAT ELSE WE
SHOULD BE DOING.
BECAUSE THIS IS JUST.
THE BILL I'M PRESENTING DOESN'T
MEAN THAT THERE AREN'T TWENTY
THIRTY FORTY DIFFERENT BILLS OUT
THERE THAT WE SHOULD BE.
THINKING ABOUT.
AND REALLY WORKING I KNOW ONE OF
THE INITIAL CONCERNS WITH THIS
TO BE OVER USE.
THAT THIS TYPE OF RESTRAINING
ORDER THEY'RE JUST BE HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS MILLIONS OF
RESTRAINING ORDER SO UP TO NOW.
IT'S BEEN IN EFFECT SINCE TWENTY
SIXTEEN THERE'S BEEN LITTLE BIT
OVER A BELIEVE TWO HUNDRED
RESTRAINING ORDERS AT FINISH.
TWO HUNDRED.
SO WE SEE THAT IT'S IN ITS IN
ITS GROWING BECAUSE NOW LAW
ENFORCEMENT ACTUALLY SEEING THIS
AS A POTENTIALLY EFFECTIVE TOOL.
FOR THEM TO GET HANDS OUT OF THE
DANGERS PEOPLE IN THEIR
NEIGHBORHOOD.
BUT AGAIN.
THE REASON THAT WE ADDED
COWORKERS ADDED SCHOOL
OFFICIALS.
I HEARD OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
PEOPLE WHO ARE TEACHERS OUR
PRINCIPALS.
PEOPLE WHO ARE IN SCHOOLS SPEND
MORE TIME WITH OUR KIDS AND WE
GET TO.
THEY ACTUALLY SEES SEE WHAT
HAPPENS.
CO WORKERS.
CO WORKERS I SPEND MORE TIME
WITH YOU THAT I DO WITH MY
DAUGHTER.
YOU ALL SEE MORE OF WHAT. WE ALL
SEE EACH OTHER A LOT MORE THAN
WE SEE OUR FIRM.
SO AGAIN IF THERE ANY RED FLAGS
THEY CAME UP.
WE WOULD PROBABLY BE THE ONES TO
ACTUALLY SEE SOME OF THE SIGNS
SOME OF THE SIGNALS.
AND HOPEFULLY WE WOULD ACT.
SO AGAIN TODAY.
I'M ASKING FOR A LITTLE BIT
ACTION FROM OUR LEGISLATURE.
TO SHOW THAT NOT TO SAY THAT WE
HAVE THE ANSWER.
BUT THAT
THIS IS A PIECE OF THE PUZZLE
FOR TRYING TO MAKE OUR STREETS
SAFER IN CALIFORNIA.
I RESPECTFULLY OSCAR AYE VOTE
ON AB TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY.
THEY WERE STAYING WITHOUT CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. I'M MEMBERS
VOTE.
THESE ARE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO GO.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLLING TALLY THE VOTE
EYES FORTY SIX KNOWS TWENTY
THREE THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEMS TWENTY AND TWENTY ONE
HOUSE RETAIN.
ALSO PASS WRITTEN A FILE AND
TWENTY TWO.
WE ARE AT FILE ITEM TWENTY
THREE.
THAT IS AB TWENTY ONE TWENTY
EIGHT QORQORI.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE TWENTY
EIGHT BY SOME REMEMBER KILEY AND
I BELIEVE THE SCHOOL EMPLOYEES.
MISTER KILEY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I AB
TWENTY ONE TWENTY EIGHT UPDATES
EXISTING K. TWELVE EMPLOYEE
DISMISSAL POLICY IN CALIFORNIA.
TO BETTER PROTECT STUDENTS FROM
SEXUAL HARASSMENT AND OTHER
INAPPROPRIATE BEHAVIOR.
IN TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN THE
LEGISLATURE UPDATED THE PROCESS
FOR DISMISSALS OF PERMANENT
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES WITH THE
PASSAGE OF AB TWO FIFTEEN.
THAT MAIL PROVIDED THE FRAMEWORK
NEEDED TO PROTECT STUDENTS FROM
SERIOUS FORMS OF MISCONDUCT BY
GIVING LOCAL SCHOOL OFFICIALS A
MECHANISM TO ASSURE AN OFFENDING
EMPLOYEES PROMPT REMOVAL FROM
THE CLASSROOM.
BUT SINCE THE PASSAGE OF AB TWO
FIFTEEN SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS
AND GOVERNING BOARDS HAVE
EXPRESSED CONCERN THAT THE LAW
DOES NOT ALLOW THEM TO
ADEQUATELY ADDRESS MISCONDUCT
INVOLVING SEXUAL HARASSMENT. AND
OTHER INAPPROPRIATE BEHAVIOR
WITH STUDENTS
AS A RESULT THERE SOME SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES THAT ARE STAYING IN
THE CLASSROOM EVEN AFTER
NUMEROUS ALLEGATIONS
OF SEXUAL MISCONDUCT.
TODAY'S BILL ADDRESSES THIS
ISSUE AND FURTHERS THE PURPOSE
OF AB TWO FIFTEEN.
WELL EXISTING LAW ONLY ALLOWS
EVIDENCE AND TESTIMONY THE DATES
BACK FOUR YEARS EXCEPT IN THE
MOST SERIOUS INSTANCES OF
ALLEGED. SEXUAL ASSAULT OR CHILD
ABUSE DURING A DISMISSAL HEARING
THIS BELT WOULD ALSO A LOT OF IT
ENDS OF SEXUAL HARASSMENT OR
OTHER INAPPROPRIATE BEHAVIOR
EVEN IF IT IS OLDER THAN FOUR
YEARS. I IN ORDER TO ESTABLISH A
PATTERN OF MISCONDUCT
TODAY'S BILL IS AN IMPORTANT
STEP IN MEETING TWO PRESSING
SOCIAL CHALLENGES MAKING OUR
SCHOOL SAFER AND ROOTING OUT
SEXUAL HARASSMENT.
THE BILL MAKES COMMONSENSE
CHANGES TO STRENGTHEN THE
EXISTING TEACHER DISMISSAL
STATUTE AND BETTER PROTECT KIDS
FROM PREDATORY BEHAVIOR THE BILL
RECEIVE UNANIMOUS SUPPORT IN THE
ASSEMBLY EDUCATION. AND
JUDICIARY COMMITTEES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR IVA.
THANK YOU MISTER KILEY.
SAYING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE ITEM.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE WRONG TIES WHEN
I SIXTY SEVEN AT NO ZERO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEMS
TWENTY FOUR.
CALDERON FOR WHAT PURPOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND THE RULES TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBER KIRK TO TAKE UP
AB TWENTY ONE TWENTY FIVE QUIRK
WITHOUT REFERENCE FIVE FOR THE
PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER
.
I RESPECT ON THE FILE FILE ITEMS
TWENTY FOUR THROUGH.
FORTY.
PASS A RETAIN
DOCTOR QUIRK HAS AMENDMENTS
COOPERATE.
FOR SOME PEOPLE TWENTY ONE
TWENTY FIVE OF THE MINUTES BY
SOME REMEMBER QUIRK.
DOCTOR PARK ON THE AMENDMENTS.
I THANK YOU MEMBERS IN SPEAKERS
FOR ALLOWING ME TO TAKE UP THIS
BILL.
ARE THESE AMENDMENTS REFLECT AN
ONGOING STAKEHOLDER DISCUSSION.
ON RISK LIMITING AUDITS WITH
THIS AMENDMENTS THE BILL WILL BE
PULLED BACK TO THE ELECTIONS
COMMITTEE. FOR FULL DISCUSSION
AND ANALYSIS.
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WORK. WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE MEMBERS ARE
ADOPTED THE BILL'S OUT TO PRINT
ABOUT ON FILE.
SURE CALDERON YOU HAVE GAS IN
THE CHAMBER.
I DO THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS IF YOU CAN JOIN ME IN
WELCOMING SOME STUDENTS AND I
HAVE BEEN FROM MY DISTRICT CAL
HIGH WHO HAVE BEEN HERE IN
SACRAMENTO. PARTICIPATING IN
MODEL YOU WHEN. THEY'VE BEEN AND
LEARNING A LOT OF THINGS THAT
THE BRIGHT FUTURE OF OUR GREAT
STATE PLEASE JOIN ME IN GIVING
THEM A WARM ASSEMBLY WELCOME
.
MEMBERS PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY
RULE SEVENTY SEVEN POINT TWO I
AM REFERRING AB TWENTY ONE
TWENTY FIVE.
TO THE ELECTIONS AND REDUCE.
COMMITTEE
.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN I'VE BEEN
TOLD THAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER BRIAN
MAIENSCHEIN AS BIRTHDAY WILL BE
HAVE.
MR MAIENSCHEIN HAPPY BIRTHDAY.
MEMBERS WE ARE BACK ON THE FILE.
WE ARE AT FILE ITEM.
FORTY ONE.
AB SEVENTEEN FORTY ONE BY MISTER
BONTA THE CLERK WILL READ.
SOME PEOPLE SEVENTEEN FORTY ONE
BY SOME MEMBER BONTA NATURALLY
THE CANNABIS MISTER BONTA EMAIL.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES AB SEVENTEEN FORTY
ONE SIMPLY REMOVES THE TEN
PERCENT PENALTY ON NON
ELECTRONIC FUND TRANSFER
PAYMENTS OVER TEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR CULTIVATION EXCISE
TAXES ON BOTH MEDICAL AND I
DON'T USE CANNABIS. AND FOR
SALES AND USE TAXES ON ADULT USE
CANNABIS IN TWENTY SIXTEEN THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED A SIMILAR
BILL AB EIGHT TWENTY ONE BY OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM CARSON. WHOEVER
THAT MEASURE ONLY APPLIED TO
SALES AND USE TAXES ON MEDICAL
CANNABIS IN NOVEMBER TWENTY
SIXTEEN CALIFORNIA VOTERS AS YOU
KNOW PASSED PROPOSITION SIXTY
FOUR. WHICH CREATED A
CULTIVATION EXCISE TAX ON
MEDICAL ENTER DON'T USE CANNABIS
AND A SALES AND USE TAX ON ADULT
USE CANNABIS AB T. AB SEVENTEEN
FORTY ONE WHAT APPLY. TO THESE
NEW TAXES
BECAUSE FEDERAL LAW CURRENTLY
CLASSIFIES CANNABISAS A
SCHEDULE ONE DRUG MOST BANKS AND
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS DO NOT
ALLOW CANNABIS BUSINESSES TO
OPEN BANK ACCOUNTS. THERE FOR
MOST CANNABIS BUSINESSES HAVE NO
CHOICE BUT TO OPERATE AND PAY
TAXES IN CASH.
AB SEVENTEEN FORTY ONE
INCENTIVIZE THE CANNABIS
INDUSTRY TO LEGALLY COMPLY WITH
CALIFORNIA TAX CODE WHICH WILL
IN TURN GENERATE MORE TAX
REVENUE FURTHER STIMULATING
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
COLLEAGUES.
THANK YOU MISTER BONTA.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM.
CLICK LIBERAL. ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
ROSARIO VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTE
DESIRE TO GO.
THIS TAKES FIFTY FOUR.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
TWO THIRDS THRESHOLD.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
S. TAKES FIFTY FOUR
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF VOTE
MEMBERS ON THE FILE FILE ITEM
FORTY TO PASS RETAIN.
FILE ITEM FORTY THREE. IS AB
TWENTY ELEVEN ARMY TWENTY ONE
NINETEEN THAT'S AB TWENTY ONE
NINETEEN BY MISTER GLORIA THE
CLERK READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE
NINETEEN BY SOME REMEMBER GLORIA
AND OTHERS AND ACT LIKE A FOSTER
CARE.
MISTER GLORIA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
TO PRESENT AB TWENTY ONE
NINETEEN AND IMPORTANT BILL THAT
WILL ENSURE THAT TRANSGENDER AND
GENDER NON CONFORMING YOUTH IN
FOSTER CARE HAVE ACCESS TO
APPROPRIATE. HEALTH CARE AND
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CARE SERVICES.
FORCING MEMBERS MANY OF YOU KNOW
THE TRANSGENDER AND GENDER NON
CONFORMING USE ARE SIGNIFICANTLY
OVER REPRESENTED IN CALIFORNIA'S
FOSTER CARE SYSTEM.
AND FORTUNATELY BIAS AND
MISINFORMATION SOMETIMES
CONCRETE BARRIERS TO THESE
CHILDREN RECEIVING MEDICALLY
NECESSARY TREATMENT.
CURRENT LAW REQUIRES THAT EVERY
CHILD. WELFARE AGENCY TO ASSESS
THE HEALTH NEEDS OF THE YOUNG
PEOPLE IN THEIR CARE AND TO
ENSURE THEY RECEIVE APPROPRIATE
AND TIMELY CARE TO ADDRESS THE
NEEDS IDENTIFIED BY QUALIFIED
PROFESSIONALS.
AB TWENTY ONE NINETEEN REQUIRES
THAT THESE AGENCIES PROVIDE
ACCESS TO CLINICIANS WHO PROVIDE
GENDER AFFIRMING TREATMENT
CONSISTENT WITH ESTABLISHED
STANDARDS OF CARE.
NOW I WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT
THIS GENDER AFFIRMING HEALTH AND
BEHAVIORAL CARE IS SUBJECT TO
THE SAME RULES AS OTHER KINDS OF
MEDICAL CARE AND TREATMENT. I
DID THAT FOR A THAT OTHER
CHILDREN WITHIN CALIFORNIA'S
FOSTER CARE SYSTEM ALREADY
RECEIVED JUST LIVING SPECIAL
ABOUT THIS CARE IT'S JUST A
CLARIFYING THAT THE RIGHT THAT
THESE CHILDREN HAVE UNDER THE
LAW. THAT TO FOLLOW ALL THE
OTHER SAME RULES.
THE BURKE BEEN NEED TO PROVIDE
GENDER FARMING CARE IS EXTREMELY
URGENT MEMBERS FOR ADOLESCENTS
IN PARTICULAR WITHHOLDING IT
PROLONGS IT EXACERBATES GENDER
DYSPHORIA. CONTRIBUTE TO OTHER
KINDS OF CONDITIONS THE INCREASE
ABUSE AND STIGMATIZATION.
AB TWENTY ONE NINETEEN IS
SUPPORTED BY THE AMERICAN CIVIL
LIBERTIES UNIONEQUALITY
CALIFORNIA THE NATIONAL CENTER
FOR LESBIAN RIGHTS. LAMBDA LEGAL
AND THE LOS ANGELES LGBT
COMMUNITY CENTER I ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE.
THINGS GLORIA.
SAYING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE ITEM.
CLERK WILL OVER THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS CLOSER TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLERK WELL.
CLOSE YOUR OWN TIME ABOUT ICE
FORTY TWO KNOWS TWENTY ONE.
THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEMS
FORTY.
FOR THROUGH FORTY SEVEN.
PASS RETAIN.
WHERE FILE ITEM NUMBER FORTY
EIGHT AB NINETEEN NINETY NINE
FIVE MISTER CHOW? CORKERY.
SOME PEOPLE NINETEEN NINETY NINE
BY SIMPLY RIVER CHAO ACCOLADES
LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
SHOULD SHALL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS AB NINETEEN
NINETY NINE WOULD EXPAND THE
AUTHORITY OF LOCAL COMMUNITIES
TO DEVELOP PUBLIC BROADBAND
SERVICES WHILE PRESERVING NET
NEUTRALITY TO ENSURE. THE
INTERNET REMAINS OPEN AND
ACCESSIBLE TO ALL CALIFORNIANS
CALIFORNIA LAW CURRENTLY
AUTHORIZES MUNICIPAL UTILITY
DISTRICT AND PUBLIC UTILITY
DISTRICTS TO OPERATE THEIR OWN
BROADBAND NETWORKS. BUT OTHER
FORMS OF INDEPENDENT LOCAL
GOVERNMENT HAVE LIMITED
AUTHORITY TO DO SO. FOR EXAMPLE
COMMUNITY SERVICE DISTRICTS
CAN'T INITIALLY PROVIDE THE
SERVICE BUT HAVE TO SEE IT OVER
THE AUTHORITY ONCE A PRIVATE
ENTITY IS WILLING TO DEPLOY THE
SERVICE.
RESTRICTING LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
FROM BUILDING OUT THEIR OWN HIGH
SPEED NETWORKS IS
COUNTERPRODUCTIVE TO CLOSING
CALIFORNIA'S DIGITAL DIVIDE
ESPECIALLY IN RURAL AREAS WERE
ONLY FORTY THREE PERCENT. OF THE
POPULATION HAS ACCESS TO
BROADBAND IN THEIR HOUSEHOLDS OR
IN AREAS THAT ONLY HAVE ACCESS
TO ONE PROVIDER. OR WORD THERE
IS A LACK OF ONGOING INVESTMENT.
RECENTLY THE FEDERAL
COMMUNICATIONS COMMISSION FCC
TOOK ACTION TO REPEAL NET
NEUTRALITY RUSE.
THESE RULES REQUIRE INTERNET
SERVICE PROVIDERS TO OFFER EQUAL
ACCESS TO ALL WEB CONTENT
WITHOUT CHARGING CONSUMERS FOR
HIGHER QUALITY DELIVERY. OR
GIVING PREFERENTIAL TREATMENT TO
CERTAIN WEBSITES.
ACCORDING TO A RECENT STUDY
CONDUCTED BY THE UNIVERSITY OF
MARYLAND SUCH PROPOSAL BY THE F.
C. C. WAS UP. ARE MORE THAN
EIGHTY PERCENT OF THE VOTE IS
SUPPOSED TO THE HAVE SEE SEE A
PROPOSAL.
AND AS A RESULT LOCAL. OWN
BROADBAND NETWORKS AB SHOULD
BECOME THE ALTERNATIVE FOR
CONSUMERS IT SHOULD ALSO BE THE
STATE'S POLICY TO UPHOLD THE
PRINCIPLES OF AN OPEN INTERNET
BY REQUIRING ADHERENCE TO THE
CORE. PRINCIPLES OF NET
NEUTRALITY THERE'S NO OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL WRIST I
RESPECTFULLY ASK WHERE I VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS SHALL SEEING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ON THE
SHOW.
THESE ARE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF THOSE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
THE CLERK WILL.
CLOSE THE ROLE AND HOW ABOUT ICE
FORTY SEVEN KNOWS NINETEEN THAT
MEASURE PASSES
MEMBERS. WITHOUT OBJECTION WE
ARE GOING TO MOVE AHEAD IN THE
FILES TO TAKE UP FILE ITEM
EIGHTY FOUR.
WHICH IS A C. ARE TWO TWO SIX BY
MISTER RODRIGUEZ.
COOPERATE.
SWIMMING CURRENT RESOLUTION TO
TWENTY SIX BY SOME REMEMBER
RODRIGUEZ RELATIVE TO EMERGENCY
MEDICAL SERVICES WEEK MISTER
RODRIGUEZ.
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
ACR TWO TWO SIX.
RECOGNIZE MAY TWENTIETH THROUGH
MAY TWENTY SIX AS EMERGENCY
MEDICAL SERVICES WEEK IN
CALIFORNIA.
EMS WEEK AS A NATIONAL CAMPAIGN
DEDICATED TO PROFESSIONALS WHO
PROVIDE LIFESAVING CARE TO
OTHERS IN THEIR TIME OF NEED.
CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO OVER
EIGHTY THOUSAND CAREER AND
VOLUNTEER EMERGENCY MEDICAL
SERVICE PERSONNEL WHO TREAT OVER
TWO MILLION CALIFORNIANS A YEAR.
AS MANY OF YOU KNOW I'VE BEEN IN
MERGING MEDICAL TECHNICIAN FOR
OVER THIRTY YEARS. I CAN ATTEST
TO THE TRUE PROFESSIONALISM AND
PASSION THESE INDIVIDUALS BRING
TO THEIR WORK.
MEMBERS LAST YEAR WE SEEN.
HOW DEVASTATION OCCURRED ARE
PARTS OF OUR STATE WITH THE
FIRES NOT TO MENTION THE FLOODS
OF FOLLOW?
NOT TO MENTION THE DAY TODAY
BECAUSE THEY RECEIVE FROM
CHURCH.
HELPING PEOPLE ON THE SIDE OF A
ROAD FROM A TRAFFIC COLLISION.
OR GOING TO HELP SOMEONE
SUFFERING FROM A HEART ATTACK.
WORKING LONG HOURS MISSION
SPECIAL MOMENTS WITH FAMILIES
AND FRIENDS AND PUTTING THEIR
OWN LIVES ON THE LINE IS JUST
PART OF THE JOB.
THIS RESOLUTION AT THE COMMAND
OF HER SACRIFICE AND DEDICATION.
I RESPECT THE HOUSE FOR AYE VOTE
WERE LIKE TO REQUEST THAT THE
FIRST ROW BE OPEN FOR COAUTHORS.
THANK YOU MISTER RODRIGUEZ
SEEING NO DISCUSSION.
MISTER FRAZIER.
I'M SORRY MISS YOU SIR.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS
I RISE TODAY IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF ACR TO TWENTY SIX.
TO RECOGNIZE EMERGENCY MEDICAL
SERVICES WEEK.
OUR CALIFORNIA PARAMEDICS EMPTY
FLIGHT NURSES AND RESCUE SQUAD
MEMBERS ARE AMONG THE FIRST TO
RESPOND TO REGIONAL MEDICAL
EMERGENCIES AND TRAUMAS.
THESE BRAVE MEN AND WOMEN ARE
THE DEFINITION OF HEROES.
THEY WILL FOREVER HOLD A PLACE
SPECIAL IN MY HEART FOR SAVING
THE LIFE OF MY YOUNGEST
DAUGHTER.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE TO
THE PEOPLE THAT WE HOLD DEAR.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU MISTER FRAZIER.
SEEN NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION ON
THE RESOLUTION THE AUTHOR IS
ASKING THAT THE FIRST ROLE BE
OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE.
MEMBERS THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
THIS IS CO AUTHORS.
MEMBERS THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS
ON ACR TWO TWO SIX.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ALL THEIR SIXTY EIGHT
COAUTHORS ADDED ON WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION ALL THOSE
IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
YES HAVE AT THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED AND MISTER RODRIGUEZ
BACK TO YOU FOR YOUR GAS
INTRODUCTION.
MEMBERS ALSO WE ARE JOINED TODAY
IN THE GALLERY TOMORROW RIGHT BY
SOME OF THE VERY SPECIAL FOLKS.
WE HAVE REPRESENTATIVES FROM
UNITED YOU MUST WORKERS ASKED ME
LOCAL FORTY NINE ELEVEN.
THE CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL.
EMERGENCY NURSES ASSOCIATION
EMERGENCY PHYSICIANS CALIFORNIA
I'M ASSOCIATION THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS AND
CAL FIRE. PEACE OFFICERS
RESEARCH ASSERTION OF CALIFORNIA
AMERICAN MEDICAL RESPONSE PLEASE
JOIN ME IN GIVING THEM A ROUND
OF APPLAUSE
MEMBERS WE ARE BACK AND FILE
ORDER.
AND WE WILL BE TAKING UP. FILE
ITEM NUMBER FORTY NINE.
ACR TO THIRTY TWO BY MS BAKER
THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
TO THIRTY TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BAKER RELATIVE TO FOOD ALLERGY
AWARENESS WEEK.
IS BAKER YOU MAILED ME THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AM
PLEASED TO PRESENT TO YOU TODAY
ACR TO THIRTY TWO WHICH
COMMEMORATES THE WEEK OF MAY
THIRTEENTH REMAIN NINETEENTH.
AS FOOD ALLERGY AWARENESS WEEK.
AS MANY AS FIFTEEN MILLION
AMERICANS HAVE FOOD ALLERGIES
AND NEARLY SIX MILLION OF THOSE.
WHO HAVE THEM OUR CHILDREN UNDER
THE AGE OF EIGHTEEN? INCLUDING
MY SON FOR THE FIRST FIVE YEARS
OF HIS LIFE WAS I HAD LIFE
THREATENING ALLERGY TO A TREE
NUTS AND PEANUTS.
EAT FOODS BECAUSE THE MAJORITY
OF FOOD ALLERGY REACTIONS IN THE
UNITED STATES SHELLFISH FISH
EGGS MILK TREE NUTS PEANUTS SOY
AND WHEAT.
AND IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE'VE
SEEN ON THE RISE INCREASINGLY
PARTICULARLY AMONG THE LAST
DECADE AND PARTICULARLY AMONG
CHILDREN. THEY RESULTS IN OVER
TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND EMERGENCY
ROOM DEPARTMENT VISITS EACH
YEAR.
AND THE NUMBER OF FOOD ALLERGY
REACTIONS REQUIRING EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENTS OR EMERGENCY TRIPS
ROSE SHARPLY JUST IN THE PAST
TEN YEARS BY ALMOST FOUR HUNDRED
PERCENT WE DON'T KNOW. EXACTLY
WHY IT IS A BIG QUESTION AND
SCIENCE IS LOOKING INTO IT. BUT
THIS RESOLUTION IS IMPORTANT TO
INCREASE AWARENESS ABOUT THINGS
WE SHOULD KNOW. FIRST OF ALL
IT'S NOT THE PARENTS FAULT IT'S
NOT SOMETHING THE MOM DID WRONG
DURING A ANYTIME OF THE CHILD'S
EARLY LIFE OR WHEN THE CHILD WAS
IN UTERO. IT'S ALSO NOT THE
CHILD'S FAULT.
THEY HAVEN'T DONE ANYTHING WRONG
EITHER.
AND IT'S NOT JUST SOMETHING
WHERE FOOD ALLERGY ALLOWS YOU
ONCE YOU PUT THE ALLERGEN ON THE
FOOD TO TAKE IT OFF OR BRUSH IT
OFF FOR JUST SCRAPED AWAY
BECAUSE THESE ARE LIFE.
THREATENING.
ELEMENTS.
AND EVEN THE BEARER AMOUNT OF
CONTACT COULD CAUSE SOMEONE TO
GO TO THE EMERGENCY ROOM.
ANOTHER POINTS OUT JUST A FACT
ABOUT FOOD ALLERGIES IS SAM
HAPPY PANTS AND THOSE EMERGENCY
TOOLS THAT WE ALL SHOULD KNOW
HOW TO USE SCHOOLS ALL ACROSS
THE STATE SHOULD KNOW HOW TO USE
AND HAVE.
THEY'RE NOT AN ASSURANCE THAT
IT'S OKAY TO HAVE THAT FOOD
ALLERGEN IN THE AREA FOR THE
PERSON WHO'S ALLERGIC THEY BUY
YOU TIME AND SOMETIMES THEY
DON'T WORK. AND THERE ARE STILL
FATAL INCIDENCES THAT HAPPENED
EVEN AFTER THE USE OF ABBY PENS
AND BENADRYL AND EMERGENCY
INTERVENTION.
THERE'S NO CURE FOR FOOD
ALLERGIES BUT THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT WE CAN CONTINUE TO RESEARCH
AND WE SHOULD BECAUSE IT AFFECTS
EVERYONE OF OUR ASSEMBLY
DISTRICTS.
THE FOOD ALLERGY RESEARCH AND
EDUCATION ORGANIZATION IS A
NATIONAL NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION
DEDICATED TO IMPROVING THE
QUALITY OF LIFE AND THE HEALTH
OF INDIVIDUALS WITH FOOD
ALLERGIES AND PROVIDE THEM WITH
HOPE FOR MORE OPPORTUNITIES TO
LIVE FULLY IN OUR AREAS.
AGAIN INCREASINGLY A AWARENESS
ABOUT THIS IF YOU FIND TO COME
ACROSS SOMEONE WHO HAS A FOOD
ALLERGY.
PARTICULARLY CHILDREN IT
TOTALLY CHANGES THEIR LIFE THEY
CAN'T GO TO SUMMER CAMP THE SAME
WAY THAT EVERYONE ELSE CAN THEY
CAN'T GO TO BIRTHDAY PARTIES THE
SAME WAY SOMEONE ELSE CAN
SLUMBER PARTIES ARE OVER TO
SOMEONE'S HOME.
I'M THE PARENT IS ALWAYS
THINKING WHAT CAN I BE DOING IN
PROVIDING TO PROTECT MY CHILD.
AND IT'S IMPORTANT THAT IF YOU
HAVE A CHANCE AND YOU COME
ACROSS SOMEONE IN THAT SITUATION
ASK THEM HOW YOU CAN HELP.
ASK THEM HOW YOU CAN MAKE SURE
THAT THEY ARE LESS SUBJECT TO A
LIFE THREATENING CONTACT WITH
THAT. BECAUSE THAT'S PART OF HOW
WE INCREASE AWARENESS AND WE
PROTECT THOSE OF OUR
CONSTITUENTS HAVE FOOD ALLERGIES
AND TELL WERE ABLE TO FULLY TO
TREAT THEM AND HEAR THEM. AND
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE AND I DO S. THE FIRST
WILL BE OPEN FOR COAUTHORS.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS BAKER.
SEEING NO OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION ON THE ITEM IS
BAKER'S ASKING THAT THE FIRST
ROLE BE OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS ON
THE RESOLUTION CARPOOL OPEN THE
ROLL-ON.
MEMBERS THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS
CO AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON.
ACR TO THIRTY TWO.
THIS IS CO AUTHORS.
CLERK WILL CLOSE TO ROLL THEIR
SIXTY NINE CO AUTHORS ADDED AND
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
WE MAY TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
GUYS HAVE THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED.
AND MS BAKER FOR YOUR GUEST
INTRODUCTION.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I'M VERY PLEASED TO
PRESENT YOU UP IN THE GALLERY
TODAY KIM BROWN AND HER
COLLEAGUES FROM THE FOOD ALLERGY
RESEARCH AND EDUCATION
ORGANIZATION BASED IN THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA. THEY ARE
DOING WORK TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
ARE PROMOTING AWARENESS FOR
EVERYONE OF THE CALIFORNIA'S IN
OUR CONSTITUENTS WHO HAVE FOOD
ALLERGIES LET'S GIVE THEM A WARM
ASSEMBLY WELCOME THANK YOU
.
MEMBERS FILE ITEMS FIFTY AND
FIFTY ONE PASS RETAIN.
WE'RE AT FILE ITEM NUMBER FIFTY
TO AB EIGHTEEN SIXTY EIGHT BY
MISTER CUNNINGHAM THE CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN SIXTY
EIGHT BY SOME REMEMBER
CUNNINGHAM ACTUALLY THE PEOPLE
INSTRUCTION.
MISTER CUNNINGHAM.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS AB EIGHTEEN
SIXTY EIGHT. ALLOW SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THE OPTION NOT A
MANDATE BUT THE OPTION.
OF INCLUDING MATERIALS ABOUT THE
DANGERS OF SENDING SEXUALLY
EXPLICIT MATERIALS USING
CELLPHONES AND SOCIAL MEDIA. AS
PART OF THE EXISTING SEX ED
CURRICULUM.
IT ENJOYS A BROAD COALITION OF
SUPPORT AND PASSED THE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE UNANIMOUSLY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THE COMMISSIONING HIM SEEING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE.
THE RESEARCH OF ON ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF THOUGH.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE RURAL CHINA BUT I SEVENTY
NO ZERO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM
FIFTY THREE THROUGH FIFTY SEVEN
PASS RETAIN.
WHERE FILE ITEM FIFTY EIGHT?
AB TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY FIVE.
CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY EIGHT
EIGHTY FIVE BY SOME MEMBER
RODRIGUEZ AND OTHERS AND I
BELIEVE THE VEHICLE AIR
POLLUTION. MISTER RODRIGUEZ.
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY FIVE
INSURERS. DISADVANTAGE IN LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES ARE RECEIVING
NECESSARY RESOURCES TO AID IN
THE FIGHT AGAINST POOR AIR
QUALITY IN CLIMATE CHANGE.
THESE ARE AREAS LIKE MY DISTRICT
THE SUFFER FROM EXTREMELY POOR
AIR QUALITY. LOW INCOMES AND
POOR QUALITY OF HEALTH.
YET THEY DO NOT RECEIVE A FAIR
SHARE OF INVESTMENTS FROM
PROGRAMS LIKE THE C. V. R. P..
AB TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY FIVE PAR
TIES REBATES AND NOT REACH TO
THESE COMMUNITIES TO HELP HARD
WORKING FAMILIES TO DO THEIR
PART. TO COMBAT CLIMATE CHANGE I
RESPECT THREE OUT FOR AYE VOTE.
THEY WHICH RODRIGUEZ.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE ITEM.
CLICK CLUB THE ROLE. MEMBERS
VOTERS ARAB VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSER ROLE ANTI THAT
I SIXTY TWO.
NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM FIFTY NINE IS A. B.
THIRTY TO FIFTY FOR THE CLERK
WILL READ. ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY
TO FIFTY FOUR BY THE COMMITTEE
ON LOCAL GOVERNMENT NOT RELATED
TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
MS AGUILAR CURRY MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS A. B. THIRTY TO FIFTY
FOUR AS YOU ASSEMBLY LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE'S. ANNUAL
OMNIBUS BILL WHICH MAKES MINOR
IN NON CONTROVERSIAL CHANGES TO
THE STATUTES WHICH GOVERN LEFT
GOES.
THIS IS A CONSENSUS BUILDER HAS
RECEIVED NO. NO VOTES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR EYEBROWS.
THANK YOU MS SAGER CURRY SEEN NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF THOSE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
THE CLERK.
WELL CLOSER ROLE AND TALLY THE
VOTE. AYE SIXTY SEVEN. KNOWS
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS I AM PREPARED TO LIFT
THE CALL ON FILE ITEM FORTY
EIGHT.
AB SEVENTEEN FORTY ONE THE CLERK
WILL POST ON MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
FIFTY FOUR VOTE BILL ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTE
ICE FIFTY EIGHT KNOWS TWELVE.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
I WISH BACK ON THE FILE FILE
ITEM SIXTY.
IS A. C. R. TO SIXTEEN.
CORKERY.
ASSUMING CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
TO SIXTEEN BY STILL MEMBER MERCY
XIN OTHERS RELATIVE TO FIVE
TWENTY NINE COLLEGE SAVINGS A.
MISTER MURATSUCHI THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS ACR
TWENTY SIXTEEN. DECLARES THE
FIVE TWENTY NINE COLLEGE SAVINGS
STATE OF WAIVER WAIT RAISE
AWARENESS
ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF SAVING
FOR COLLEGE WITH THE HELP OF
FIVE TWENTY NINE COLLEGE
SAVINGS.
PLANS I KNOW I HAVE MY FIVE
TWENTY ONE PLAN FOR MY DAUGHTER.
BUT THAT WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE RAISE AWARENESS AT ALL
COMMUNITIES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AYE VOTE WITH THE FIRST ROLL
CALL FOR CO AUTHORS.
THANK YOU VERY VERY MUCH AS
MURATSUCHI DR CHOI HERE
RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU SPEAKER AND THE
MEMBERS SAW.
S. A LIFELONG EDUCATOR AND A
FATHER OF.
NO TWO CHILDREN WHO HAVE GONE
THROUGH OUR CALIFORNIA'S.
A HIGHER EDUCATION SYSTEM I RISE
SO IN PROUD TO SUPPORT ALL OF
OUR ENERGY OUT TO SIXTY ONE.
AS A COLLEGE PROFESSOR AND THE
PROFESSIONAL EDUCATOR I BELIEVE
THAT EDUCATION IS THE KEY. TO
ACHIEVING THE AMERICAN DREAM.
WITH THE AVERAGE COST OF A
TOURIST ON IN CALIFORNIA.
LOBBYING SO TEN THOUSAND EIGHT
HUNDRED HIS
PAST YEAR WHICH IS SOUGHT TO
HUNT JUST SEVENTEEN DOLLARS TO
HIGHER THAN THE NATIONAL
AVERAGE.
THIS CAN BE A HUGE BURDEN ON NOT
ON THE STUDENTS
BUT THE FAMILIES SUCH TRYING TO
A SUPPORT THEIR OWN CHILDREN.
WHO ARE WHEN I'M RECEIVE A
HIGHER EDUCATION?
IN FACT ACCORDING TO ON AVERAGE.
ONE AND A CITY.
ANALYSIS ARE CONDUCTED BY ABOUT
BOTH THE UNIVERSITY SYSTEMS SO
THE AVERAGE.
UC'S STOOD ON OUR GRADUATES.
OUT WITH THE TWENTY.
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS TO
IN DATA AND THE AVERAGE JUST CSU
STUDENTS ARE EIGHTEEN THOUSAND
SIX HUNDRED.
OF FOUR HUNDRED SIXTY DOLLARS SO
IN THAT.
DECIMATING MAY TWENTY NINTH. AS
SO FIVE TWENTY NINE COLLEGES
THEY WERE NOT BRING A WIN AS SO
TO GO SO.
WHO DO NOT THE REALIZED HOW
EXTREMELY DIFFICULT? IT IS SO
FOR OVER CALIFORNIA CITIZENS SO
TO BE. A PART OF THE HIGHER
EDUCATION SYSTEM.
IT WILL ALSO HELP OUR FAMILIES.
UNDERSTAND THE IMPORTANCE OF OF
US SAVING MONEY FOR THE OUR
CHILDREN TO ATTEND THE
UNIVERSITY'S.
OUR AND US STATE COLLEGES SO.
IN FACT NO FOR MY UP A BRAND NEW
GRAN. A TILE DOT I WOULD MAKE
SURE THAT THE.
MY.
A SENATE KNOWING THAT THE ORDER
WAS TECH OF VANTAGEONE BUDGET SO
FIVE HUNDRED TWENTY NINE
ONCOLOGIST SAVINGS A PLAN.
I AM CHIEF
ARE A TRUE BELIEVER NOT THAT NOT
THAT ONCE A PERSON CAN EVER BE
ALL OVER EDUCATED. AND FOR THIS
REASON THOUGHT I RESPECTFULLY.
URGE ON AYE VOTE THOUGHT ON THIS
MEASURE THANK.
THANK YOU GET CHOI MR MCCARTY
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I AM. PROUD JOINT
AUTHOR OF THIS MEASURE WITH MY
COLLEAGUE FOR HIM TORRANCE
RECOGNIZING MAY TWENTY NINTH AS
FIVE TWENTY NINE DAY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. DON'T WANT TO
BELABOR THE. INFORMATION LAID
OUT WE KNOW IT'S A WIN FOR
CALIFORNIA WE NEED MORE COLLEGE
GRADUATES IN OUR STATE. FOR THE
JOBS OF TODAY AND TOMORROW WE
ALSO KNOW THAT COLLEGE COSTS.
MORE AND MORE MONEY
UNFORTUNATELY AND SAVING FOR
COLLEGE IS SO CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT BUT ONE FACT THAT
PEOPLE. DON'T ALWAYS RECOGNIZE
IF YOU LOOK AT PEOPLE WHO SAVE
MONEY FOR COLLEGE RESEARCH SHOWS
THAT YOUR FAMILY SAVES.
FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS OR FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS THESE
STUDENTS ARE STILL FOUR TIMES
MORE LIKELY TO GOING TO COLLEGE
IF YOU HAVE ANY. BIT OF IMPRINT
MONEY SAVED IN A COLLEGE ACCOUNT
SO IT'S GOOD TO START SMALL GOOD
GOOD TO START ON THE TWENTY
NINTH OF MAY. AND WE ASK
CALIFORNIANS TO JOIN AND SAY FOR
OUR FUTURE AND SAVE FOR COLLEGE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MR MCCARTY.
SEEN NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE MISTER MERCY SHE'S ASKING
THAT THE FIRST ROLE BE OPEN FOR
CO AUTHORS.
ON THE RESOLUTION.
CLERK LIBERAL. VERSUS CO
AUTHORS.
CO AUTHORS ON ACR TO SIXTEEN
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLE.
THERE SIXTY SEVEN CO AUTHORS
ADDED WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY
TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
YES HAVE A THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED.
FILE ITEM SIXTY ONE.
A SEE ARE TWO TO ONE CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
TO TWENTY ONE BY SOME WE'VE EVER
BIGELOW RELATIVE TO CALIFORNIA
FAIRGROUNDS APPRECIATION MONTH.
MISSION BIGELOW EMAIL THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I
RISE TODAY TO PRESENT ACR TWO TO
ONE WHICH DESIGNATES THE MONTH
OF MAY AS CALIFORNIA FAIRGROUND.
APPRECIATION MONTH.
THEIR SEASON IS HEREBY FRANCE.
MOST OF THE TIME WE THINK ABOUT
FAIRS WE. WE THINK ABOUT THE
RIDES THE GAMES HORSE RACING.
AND THE DELICIOUS FOOD.
TWO OF MY FAVORITES INCLUDE THE
CORN DOG AND A CINNAMON ROLL.
HOWEVER ARE SEVENTY EIGHT FAIRS
MEANS SO MUCH MORE TO OUR
COMMUNITIES THEN FRIED TWINKIES
AND FERRIS WHEELS.
IN FACT THIS LAST YEAR WE SAW
JUST HOW.
THEIR GROUNDS PROVIDE CRUCIAL
OPEN SPACE FOR EMERGENCY
RESPONSE SITUATIONS.
THEY'RE A VITAL STAGING AREA FOR
FIREFIGHTERS AND EMERGENCY
RESPONDERS DURING OUR WILDFIRE
SEASON.
THIS IS IMPORTANT TO OUR FIREMEN
AND THE PEOPLE RESPONDING TO
HAVE A PLACE TO REST.
A PLACE TO REJUVENATE.
COMING BACK FROM THE FRONT LINES
A PLACE TO JUST SHOWER.
THEY'RE ALSO UTILIZED AS A SAFE
HAVEN DURING THE CATASTROPHIC
DISASTERS SUCH AS THE WILDFIRES
THE FLOODING AND EARTHQUAKES.
FOR THE DOGS THE CATS THE GOATS
THE CHICKENS.
LIVE STOCKS.
AND EVEN HUMANS.
A BIG THANK YOU NEEDS TO GO OUT
TO THE MANY VOLUNTEERS WHO HELP
OPEN THESE FAIRGROUNDS BECAUSE
THERE'S NOT ENOUGH STAFF OR NO
STAFF AT ALL.
THE FAIRGROUNDS.
AND A HUGE THANK YOU TO THOSE
WHO. ACTUALLY CAME OUT AND HELP
FEED.
THOSE ANIMALS.
AND THE PEOPLE.
THESE FACILITIES ARE WHERE WE
SHOW OFF THE BEST OF WHAT. WE
HAVE WHAT ARE REGION'S HAVE TO
OFFER. ARE WHINER TECHNOLOGY OUR
LIVESTOCK AND OUR NATURAL
RESOURCES A GOOD EXAMPLE OF THIS
CAN BE SEEN AT THE OLD SCHOOL
NO.
AT THE AMADOR COUNTY FAIR IN
PLYMOUTH WERE YOU CAN SEE HOW
TECHNOLOGY THAT WE HAVE THAT WE
TAKE FOR GRANTED TODAY.
WITH COMPUTERS AND LASERS.
HOW THEY ACTUALLY WOULD MAIL
LOGS?
WITH NOTHING MORE THAN A
MEASURING STICK.
AND THEY HAD NO ELECTRICITY SO
WHAT'S ALL CHAIN OPERATED OR
BELT OPERATED IT'S A GREAT PLACE
FOR YOU TO GO AND SEE HOW THEY.
SURVIVED IN THOSE TIMES.
THE OPPORTUNITIES FAIRGROUNDS
PROVIDE TO DISPLAY AGRICULTURAL
PRODUCTS AND LIVESTOCK BRING TO
THE FOREFRONT OF THE IMPORTANCE
AND REALITY OF FARMING AND
RANCHING FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS.
OUR LOCAL FAIRS WHERE ARE YOU IS
PREPARED TO BECOME THE NEXT
GENERATION OF FARMERS AND
RANCHERS AND ARTISTS.
MAYBE EVEN A CHAMPION JUMPING
FROG AND I'D LIKE TO PERSONALLY
THANK ALL OF YOU FOR
PARTICIPATING IN THE FORTY
FOURTH ANNUAL. OF FRAUD JUBILEE
ARE OUT HERE ON THE CAPITALS.
STEPS.
I ALSO WANT TO MENTION. THAT
EFFORT GROUNDS ARE ALSO USED FOR
OTHER GREAT THINGS AND ONE OF
THEM IN PARTICULAR. IS THE
CALIFORNIA DENTAL ASSOCIATION
WHO USES OUR FAIRGROUNDS TO PUT
A SMILE.
BACK ON FACES WHO NO LONGER
SMILED BUT NOW THEY CAN.
BECAUSE THEY HAVE A GOOD SET OF
TEETH.
UP AND DOWN THE STATE.
THIS ORGANIZATION PUTS ON THESE
GREAT CLINICS TO HELP PEOPLE
WITH TREMENDOUS ISSUES.
LAST YEAR THE CALIFORNIA STATE
FAIR.
WHAT CELEBRATED ITS FIFTIETH
ANNIVERSARY MARK THE AND LET ME
GIVE YOU SOME TRIVIA? JUST GO
STRAIGHT TO THE POINT SIX
HUNDRED THIRTY SIX THOUSAND SIX
HUNDRED TWENTY EIGHT PEOPLE
ATTENDED THE CALIFORNIA STATE
FAIR.
THIRTY TWO THOUSAND HORSE RACING
FANS CAME OUT TO THE RACETRACK
AND BET.
NINETEEN THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED
AND SIXTY TO WINDS LET'S USE
WERE SIR AND I HAD A COUPLE OF
THEM MYSELF.
SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND CORN DOGS
WERE CONSUMED.
AND THE YOUTH JUNIOR SALE.
WELL TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY
THOUSAND.
THREE HUNDRED AND FORTY FOUR
DOLLARS THEIR HIGHEST IN THE
PAST DECADE.
I DON'T KNOW HOW MUCH FUNNEL
CAKE A QUESTION WAS ANSWERED IN
THE AIR JUST GENERALLY.
BUT I WILL SAY.
THE LOCAL ECONOMIES HAVE A
TREMENDOUS BENEFIT.
MEMBERS THESE FACILITIES ARE
WHERE WE MAKE CHERISHED
MEMORIES.
WITH THIS IN MIND I WOULD ALSO
LIKE TO ADVOCATE ON BEHALF OF
FAIR GROUNDS TO ENSURE THE
RECEIVE THE FUNDING THEY
DESPERATELY NEED TO ADDRESS
THEIR DEFERRED MAINTENANCE.
TO BE USED FOR TWO GENERATIONS
IN THE FUTURE.
I STRONGLY URGE ALL MY
COLLEAGUES TO GO OUT AND TAKE A
LOOK AT THOSE FACILITIES.
AS THEY ATTEND THEIR LOCAL FAIR.
AND ENJOY ALL THE FAIR GROUNDS
THAT AND WHAT THEY HAVE TO
OFFER.
MEMBERS.
SPEAKER I WOULD ASK THAT THE
ROLL CALL BE OPEN FOR COAUTHORS.
THEY COMMISSION BAYLOR MS BAKER.
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I
THINK OUR COLLEAGUE FROM O'NEILL
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD AND
ENCOURAGE ALL MEMBERS TO OF
COURSE VISIT AMADOR COUNTY AND
THEN COME TO ALAMEDA COUNTY
FAIRGROUNDS.
WHICH IS BEEN HOME TO THE
ALAMEDA COUNTY FAIR SINCE
NINETEEN TWELVE FOR HUNDRED AND
SIX YEARS.
IT'S ALSO THE HOME TO THE OLDEST
ONE MILE HORSE TRACK IN THE
UNITED STATES ITS BEEN
OPERATIONAL SINCE EIGHTEEN FIFTY
EIGHT.
AND WITHIN THAT HORSE TRACK IS A
NINE HOLE GOLF COURSE.
AND AROUND IT IS A THREE
THOUSAND SEAT AMPHITHEATER.
SINCE NINETEEN FIFTY NINE THE
ALAMEDA COUNTY FAIRGROUNDS IN
PLEASANTON HAVE BEEN THE HOME OF
THE ALAMEDA COUNTY RAIL
AUTHORITIES.
MODEL.
TRAIN SYSTEM WHICH IS A SIGHT TO
SEE AS IS JUST ABOUT EVERYTHING
ELSE AT A COUNTY FAIR.
THIS FAIRGROUNDS Y. PLACES IT'S
IN THE TOP FIFTY FAIRS THE
UNITED STATES AND ITS IN THE
SEVENTH LARGEST FAIR IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND AS OUR GOOD COLLEAGUE FROM
O'NEILL MENTIONED YOU DO
DEFINITELY HAVE CHERISHED
MEMORIES OURS ARE OF OUR KIDS
GETTING TO SEE FIREWORKS FOR THE
FIRST TIME AT THE ALAMEDA COUNTY
FAIRGROUNDS.
IT'S FAMILY FUN IT'S AGRICULTURE
AND LIVESTOCK ITS COMPETITION
AND LET ME GIVE YOU A SAMPLE OF
SOME OF THE COMPETITIONS THAT
YOU CAN EXPERIENCE AT THE
ALAMEDA COUNTY FAIRGROUNDS.
THE GUITAR CHOCOLATE CONTEST
DAD'S FAVORITE DESSERT CONTEST
THE CHEESE CAKE CONTEST THE
FAVORITE COOKIE CONTEST THE
MYSTERY COOKING CONTEST THE
FAMILY'S FAVORITE PIE CONTEST
THE CUPCAKE CONTEST THE CUPCAKE
DECORATING CONTEST.
DUCK TAPE ART.
A CARTON CRASS LITERATURE BASE
START BLOEMAERT MISTER CALF
OREGON ME PAPER PLATE ART. AND
OF COURSE PIPE CLEANER CRAFTS
THIS IS AT THE ALAMEDA COUNTY
FAIRGROUNDS.
AND I STRONGLY ENCOURAGE ALL
MEMBERS TO BE VISITING THERE
COUNTY FAIRS AND JUST REMEMBER
THAT DEEP FRIED GOODNESS
DELICIOUSNESS THAT YOU CAN GET
AT ALL THE FAIRS THROUGHOUT THE
SUMMER. RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE AND DEFINITELY THINK
OUR MEMBER FROM O'NEILL PLEASE
STOP BY AMADOR COUNTY AND COME
TO ALAMEDA COUNTY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MS BAKER.
MS AGUILAR CURRY MISTER SPEAKER
I WOULD BE A MESS OF NOT TO
THINK THE FAIRGROUNDS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE PARTICULARLY WHEN WE
HAD THE FIRES. THEY ENDED UP
BEING EMERGENCY EMERGENCY
SHELTERS FOR MANY OF OUR
EVACUEES THEY OPEN UP THE DOORS.
THEY OFFERED US.
IN HOME FOR MANY OF OUR PEOPLE
AND I WANT TO THANK AFFAIRS FOR
DOING THAT THEY WERE.
INCREDIBLE THEY ENDED UP BEING
A REFUGE FOR MANY OF OUR FRIENDS
FROM THE CINEMA DEVELOPMENTAL
CENTER. AND THEY WERE STAY THERE
IN A SAFE COMFORTABLE PLACE
UNTIL THEY COULD RETURN HOME I
APPRECIATE ALL THE WORK THE
CALIFORNIA FAIRS DO. AND I ASK
YOU TO VOTE FOR YOU SEE OUR TWO
TO ONE.
THANK YOU MS AGAR CURRY.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL MEMBERS
SEEKING RECOGNITION.
MISTER BIGELOW YOU MAY CLOSE IF
YOU WISH.
SHE BIGELOW AS ASSET THE FIRST
WILL BE OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS ON
THE RESOLUTION CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLL-ON.
MEMBERS THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS
ON THE RESOLUTION.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS THE CLERK
WILL.
CLOSE ROLE THERE ARE SEVENTY ONE
CO AUTHOR SAT ON THE RESOLUTION
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE
TAKE A VOICE VOTE. ALL THOSE IN
FAVOR SAY AYE. AYE OPPOSED SAY
NAY.
AS HAVE IT THAT RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED AND MISTER BIGELOW BACK
TO YOU FOR YOUR SPECIAL GAS
INTRODUCTION THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER FIRST I'D LIKE TO INVITE
ALL THE MEMBERS.
TO COME BY AND ENJOY FAIR FOOD
ON BACK HERE IN THE WILLIE
BROWN.
ROOM IT IS A HOSTED BY THE
WESTERN FAIRS ASSOCIATION AND
THE CALIFORNIA STATE FAIR UPON
THE ADJOURNMENT. SO IF YOU DAHLE
COMEBACK BUT AT LAST WE LIKE TO.
HAVE YOU ALL LOOK UP IN THE
GALLERY I'D LIKE TO RECOGNIZING
GIVE A BIG WELCOME TO SARA
CUMMINGS THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE WESTERN FAIRS
ASSOCIATION.
AND RICK PICKERING THE C. E. O.
OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE FAIR.
MEMBERS WHERE FILE ITEM NUMBER
SIXTY TWO AC ARE.
TWO THIRTY SEVEN.
CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
TO THIRTY SEVEN BY SOME THE
RIVER COOLEY ANOTHER'S RELATIVE
TO FOSTER CARE MONTH.
MISTER COOLEY.
COLLEAGUES ARE MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS I'M.
PLEASED TO RISE TODAY IN SUPPORT
OF ACR TO THIRTY SEVEN. TOOK
CARE OF THE MONTH OF MAY FOSTER
CARE MONTH.
OF CHILDREN IN FOSTER CARE HAVE
BEEN REMOVED FROM THEIR FAMILIES
TO TO ABUSE OR NEGLECT.
OFTEN WITH SYMPTOMS.
SYMPTOMATIC OF POST TRAUMATIC
STRESS SYNDROME.
OF WHILE THE GOAL IS TO REUNIFY
THESE CHILDREN WITH THEIR
FAMILIES.
WE KNOW THAT DOES NOT ALWAYS
HAPPEN.
SAID THESE CHILDREN CAN END UP
WITH RELATIVE CAREGIVERS FOSTER
FAMILIES OR GROUP HOMES.
INDEED TWO OF MY FIVE
GRANDCHILDREN.
.
JOIN THE COOLEY FAMILY OUT OF
THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM HERE IN
SACRAMENTO COUNTY.
.
EACH MAY WE RECOGNIZE MAYES
FOSTER CARE MONTH
TO PUT AWARENESS ON THE ISSUES
THE CHILDREN FACE GROWING UP.
THE CHALLENGES THEY HAVE AND
LOOKED WAYS TO SUPPORT THEM.
TO PUT THE PAST BEHIND THEM.
AND TO AFFIRM A BETTER FUTURE.
WE NO THE FOSTER YOU DO
CHARACTERISTICALLY HAVE LOWER
LEVELS OF ACHIEVEMENT.
APPOINTMENT HOUSES STABILITY.
WITH INCREASED INCIDENCES OF
MENTAL ILLNESS DRUG AND ALCOHOL
ABUSE
AND EVEN HOMELESSNESS.
SO COLLEAGUES I IT IS VITAL THAT
WE CONTINUE TO LIFT UP. THIS
POPULATION CALIFORNIA TO HAVE
THEIR BACK AS IT WERE.
AND TO PROVIDE THEM WITH THE
SUPPORTS AND SERVICES THEY NEED
TO THRIVE AND GROW AND
INDEPENDENT ADULTHOOD.
I ASK YOUR AYE VOTE AND I
REQUEST THE FIRST WILL BE OFF.
OPEN FOR COAUTHORS.
THINGS COOLEY MISTER GIBSON.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR SPEAKING
MEMBERS I RISE AS A PROUD JOINT
AUTHORED ACR.
TO THIRTY SEVEN FALL SO YOU
FACE INCREDIBLE CHALLENGES IN
THEIR LIFETIME THEIR EDUCATION
AND AND MENTAL HEALTH IS
DISTURBED.
BY REMOVING THEM FROM HOME TO
HOME A ONE TO PUT UP.
PAUSE FOR A MOMENT I MET AN
INCREDIBLE ON FOSTER YOU WHO
HAVE BEEN. MOVED.
HUNDRED AND SIXTY EIGHT TIMES
AND THAT PERSON IS ONLY SIXTEEN
YEARS OLD.
CAN YOU IMAGINE A HUNDRED AND
SIXTY EIGHT TIMES BEING MOVED
FROM PLACE TO PLACE TO PLACE.
AND THEY LOSE CONNECTION TO
VALUABLE FRIENDS AND FAMILY
ALONG THE WAY. YET THEIR
RESILIENCE INSPIRE ME OUR JOB IS
TO AND I'M SURE OF FOSTER YOUTH
HAVE THE SAME OPPORTUNITIES AS
OUR OWN CHILDREN AND OTHER
CHILDREN.
SOME OF THE FOSTER YOUTH WHO
HAVE DONE SOME GREAT THINGS IN
OUR IN OUR COUNTRY.
SOME OF YOU MAY NOT KNOW A
TIFFANY HATICE.
JOHN LYNDON.
EDDIE MURPHY.
STEVE JOBS.
SHARE.
JAMES DEAN.
THEY WENT ON AND DONE SOME GREAT
INCREDIBLE THINGS BECAUSE ALONE
THE WAY THEY RECEIVED SOME OF
THINGS THAT THEY NEEDED IN ORDER
TO PROPEL THEM INTO SUCCESS AND
ALSO MARILYN MONROE. AND SO AS
WE CELEBRATE AND ALSO PAY
RECOGNITION TO.
THIS A ACR I RESPECTFULLY ASK
WHAT I VOTE TO SEND A CLEAR
MESSAGE HIS BODY SUPPORT OFF
FOSTER YOU.
MS RACE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AYE AS A PROUD MEMBER OF
THE SELECT COMMITTEE ON FOSTER
CARE AYE TO RISE IN SUPPORT OF A
SEE ARE TWO THIRTY SEVEN. AND I
THANK MY COLLEAGUE FOR MUCH OF
CORDOBA FOR PRESENTING THIS.
THEY'RE CURRENTLY SIXTY TWO
THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED AND FORTY
FOUR CALIFORNIA CHILDREN AND
YOUTH IN THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM.
AND IT IS CRITICAL THAT WE
PROVIDE THEM WITH STABLE HOMES
AND CONNECTIONS WITH LOVING
GUARDIANS.
AND IMPORTANT THING THAT WE MUST
CONTINUE TO FOCUS ON IS THE
TRANSITION FROM ADOLESCENCE TO
ADULTHOOD WHICH CAN BE DIFFICULT
AND INTIMIDATING FOR ANYONE. BUT
ESPECIALLY FOR INDIVIDUALS
LEAVING THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM.
NATIONAL LEAGUE CLOSE TO THIRTY
THOUSAND FOSTER YOUTH WILL AGE
OUT OF CARE. EVERY YEAR.
AND I ASKED IMMEDIATELY BECOME
SELF SUFFICIENT.
UNFORTUNATELY WITHIN FOUR YEARS
OF EMANCIPATION CURRENTLY
APPROXIMATELY FIFTY PERCENT OF
FORMER FOST YOU BECOME
UNEMPLOYED.
OR HOMELESS.
IT IS CRITICAL THAT WE SUPPORT
FOSTER YOUTH NOT ONLY WHILE
THEY'RE IN THE SYSTEM BUT ENSURE
THAT THEY HAVE THE RESOURCES
THEY NEED TO BE SUCCESSFUL UPON
EXITING AS WELL.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON ACR.
TWO THIRTY SEVEN.
THEY MISS RATES MR ACOSTA YOUR
RECOGNIZE.
SUPPORT AND I'D LIKE TO JUST
POINT OUT THAT THESE FOSTER.
ARE OUR CHILDREN WE'RE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THEM I
OFTENTIMES WE TAKE HIM OUT OF OF
HOMES THAT ARE NOT A GOOD
ENVIRONMENT FOR THEM THE PARENTS
MIGHT BE INCARCERATED WHATEVER
THE CIRCUMSTANCES. WE ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THESE CHILDREN
WE OWE IT TO THEM TO NOT ONLY
MAKE SURE THAT THEY GET A GOOD
EDUCATION BUT THEIR
EXTRACURRICULAR ACTIVITIES ARE
TAKING CARE OF THAT THEIR UP PRE
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS.
THINGS LIKE.
MAKING SURE THE CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION IS THERE AND
FOR AND THEY'RE AND SOLID FOR
THEM IN THE STATE ONE OF THE
THINGS KEEP IN MIND A STATISTIC
THAT IS FRIGHTENING IS THAT LESS
THAN HALF GRADUATE FROM HIGH
SCHOOL. AND AND A LESS THAN
THREE TO FOUR PERCENT OF THEM GO
ON TO A FOUR YEAR COLLEGE DEGREE
SO THAT'S WHY THINGS LIKE
CORRECT TECHNICAL EDUCATION.
THE TRADES.
COMMUNITY COLLEGES THESE ARE
GREAT STEPPING STONES FOR ARE
THESE CHILDREN AND I COMMEND THE
AUTHOR.
AND I REALLY APPRECIATE THE
FACT THAT WERE WERE PUTTING A
FOCUS ON THIS TODAY AND THIS
MONTH AND I'D REALLY ENCOURAGE
ALL OF YOU TO TAKE A LOOK AT ALL
THE WAYS THAT WE CAN HELP OUR
FOSTER YOU THROUGHOUT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. BECAUSE THEY ARE
A VERY BIG PART OF OUR FUTURE
AND EVERY CHILD THAT WE CAN SAVE
FROM A A LIFE OF DESPAIR AND
DESTRUCTION WILL BE ANOTHER
CHILD THAT IS A PRODUCTIVE
MEMBER OF OUR SOCIETY. AND I
STRONGLY URGE AN AYE VOTE ON ACR
TO THIRTY SEVEN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER COSTA
DOCTOR CHOI YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU SPEAKER AND THE
MEMBERS AGAIN.
AS A MEMBER OF DIAZ A SELECT
COMMITTEE ON NO FOSTER CARE I
RISE IN SUPPORT OF WHAT ACR.
TWO THIRTY SEVEN.
I IS IMPORTANT NOT TO RECOGNIZE
THAT THE IMPACT.
FOSTER CARE HAS SOUGHT IN
PROVIDING NOT DISPLAYED TO YOU
SO.
UP WITH THE HOMES AND THE FAMILY
CONNECTIONS.
ACCORDING TO THE. ORANGE COUNTY
REGISTER THERE ARE CURRENTLY IS
SICK BUCK TO TWENTY THREE
HUNDRED AND A FOR FOSTER KIDS
ARE LIVING IN ORANGE COUNTY. ALL
OF WHOM ARE LOOKING FOR PLAY
SOFTLY AT THAT CAN CALL HOME.
CALIFORNIA NEEDS SOME MORE
FOSTER PARENTS SO WHO CAN
PROVIDE SAFER AND A NURTURING
HOME.
ENVIRONMENT SO FULL. IS
CHILDREN.
I JOIN NOT WITH MY ESTEEMED
COLLEAGUES. IN THE RECOGNIZING
THE IMPORTANCE OF A FOSTER CARE
AND THAT THE ROLE IT PLAYS
SOCCER IN CHILD DEVELOPMENT.
WITH YEAH PASSING OF THIS OVER A
SOLUTION I HOPE THAT WE CAN NOW
REYES TOP AWARENESS.
ABOUT THIS ARE IMPORTANT ISSUE
FOR AWHILE FOSTER CHILDREN.
I SALUTE OR THE FOSTER PARENTS
SO.
IN THE STATE AND THAT IN MY
DISTRICT AND THE MORE SORTS
COUNTY I URGE YOU ARE I'VE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DOCTOR CHOI SEEN NO.
OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION MISTER COOLEY MAKE
CLOTHES IF YOU WISH.
COLLEAGUES I ACTUALLY JOIN ME AS
COAUTHORS ON THIS MEASURE I
THINK MY COLLEAGUES WHO HAVE
RECITED THAT FIGURE. ALMOST
SIXTY TWO THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED
FORTY FOR YOUTH IN OUR FOSTER
CARE SYSTEM IN CALIFORNIA.
AND I WILL DRAW THAT LINE FROM
MY COLLEAGUE FROM IRVINE THE
ASPIRATION IS WE PROVIDE THESE
WITH A SAFE AND NURTURING
ENVIRONMENT.
A QUESTION RIGHT VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER COOLEY AND YOU
WOULD LIKE THE FIRST ROLE TO BE
OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS THAT'S
CORRECT.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE MEMBERS
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
CO AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION.
THIS IS CO AUTHORS.
ADDING ONTO ACR TO THIRTY SEVEN.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLL THEIR SIXTY SEVEN CO
AUTHORS ADDED TO WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE WE TAKE A VOICE
VOTE. ON THE RESOLUTION AND ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
I AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
YES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED.
PASS RETAIN A FILE ITEM SIXTY
THREE AND SIXTY FOUR.
THAT BRINGS US
WHICH WERE TO PASS TEMPORARILY
ON FILE ITEM SIXTY FOUR.
LET'S TAKE UP FILE ITEM NUMBER
SIXTY FIVE THAT IS AB TWENTY
THREE TWENTY NINE CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE
TWENTY NINE BY SOME REMEMBER
OBERNOLTE AN ACCOLADE A SPECIAL
DISTRICTS.
MISTER OBERNOLTE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB
TWENTY THREE TWENTY NINE WOULD
STANDARDIZE THE RULES GOVERNING
THE COMPENSATION FOR DIRECTORS
OF CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS.
CURRENTLY EACH TYPE OF SPECIAL
DISTRICT IN CALIFORNIA IS
GOVERNED BY ITS OWN SECTION OF
STATE CODE WHICH HAS LED TO A
VARIETY OF DIFFERENT RULES
GOVERNING THE COMPENSATION OF
BOARD MEMBERS FOR THOSE SPECIAL
DISTRICTS.
AB TWENTY THREE TWENTY NINE WILL
LEVEL THE PLAYING FIELD BY
CREATING A SINGLE STANDARD FOR
MOSTTYPES OF CALIFORNIA SPECIAL
DISTRICTS.
PLEASE NOTE THAT THIS MEASURE IS
MERELY PERMISSIVE CHANGES TO
COMPENSATION OF ANY DISTRICT
BOARD MEMBER WOULD HAVE TO BE
APPROVED AND INITIATED BY THE
BOARD OF THAT PARTICULAR SPECIAL
DISTRICT. MEMBERS THIS IS
COMMONSENSE LEGISLATION AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER OBERNOLTE.
SAYING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE ITEM.
CLERK WILL OVER THE ROLL-ON
MEMBER SERVICE OUT OF VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLE.
AND HOW THE VOTE.
I SIXTY TWO.
NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
AND RESERVE FILE ITEM NUMBER
SIXTY SIX.
AB THIRTY SIXTY NINE.
CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY SIXTY NINE
BY SIMPLY COOPER AN ACCOLADE THE
CANNABIS.
MISTER COOPER.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
CURRENT REGULATIONS MAKE IT
DIFFICULT
THE GOVERNMENT AGENCIES TOLD
CANNABIS INFORMATIONAL
EDUCATIONAL AND TRAINING EVENTS.
AB THIRTY SIXTY NINE WOULD MAKE
SOME EXEMPTIONS FOR GOVERNMENT
AGENCIES.
PRODUCTS TO TRAIN EMPLOYEES.
AB THIRTY SIX NINE WILL HAVE
MERCY WORKERS SOCIAL SERVICE
STAFF AND FIRST RESPONDERS THE
INFORMATION THEY NEED TO KEEP
CURRENT. ON CANNABIS RELATED
REGULATIONS
OUR SPLIFF WE ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER COOPER SAYING
NO DISCUSSION DEBATE. ON THE
ITEM
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ON
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE THOUGH ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS THERE TO VOTE.
THIS TAKES FIFTY FOUR.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOTHES ARE ALL TIED UP.
I SIXTY FOUR NEWS ZERO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
WE ARE GOING TO PASS AND RETAIN
ON FILE ITEM SIXTY SEVEN.
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE A FILE ITEM
SIXTY EIGHT AB TWENTY SEVENTY
ONE BY MR BLOOM THE CLERK WILL
READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SEVENTY ONE
BY SOME REMEMBER BLOOM ACRYLATE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
MR BLOWN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
AB TWENTY SEVENTY ONE WILL
REMOVE LIABILITY RELATED TO
UTILITY SYSTEM FAILURE OR DAMAGE
TO STRUCTURES. THAT ARE BUILT
BEFORE JANUARY FIRST TWENTY
SEVENTEEN THAT ARE THEN
CONVERTED TO ACCESSORY DWELLING
UNITS AFTER JANUARY FIRST TWENTY
SEVENTEEN.
THIS BILL COULD FREE UP ANOTHER
FOUR TO SIX HUNDRED PERMITS THAT
ARE CURRENTLY STALLED. DUE TO A
VERY SEATS A SPECIFIC AND UNIQUE
ISSUE CONCERNING OVERHEAD
POWERLINES IN GARAGE CONVERSIONS
FOR EXISTING HOMES IN THE CITY
OF LOS ANGELES. WITHOUT THIS
CHANGE LADWP WILL NOT BE ABLE TO
ALLOW THESE UNITS TO BE
CONVERTED. UNLESS PARTS OF THE
BUILDING OR ACTUALLY REMOVED
FROM THE EASEMENT. WHICH OF
COURSE WOULD OUT SIGNIFICANT AND
LIKELY PROHIBITIVE COSTS TO
APPLICANTS OR REDUCE THE NUMBER
OF UNITS.
AT THAT ARE BUILT IN THE CITY.
THIS WOULD ALSO DISCOURAGE
HOMEOWNERS FROM SEEKING PERMITS
FOR EXISTING NON PERMITTED
CONVERSIONS WHICH WOULD RESULT
IN THE CONTINUATION OF ILLEGAL
STRUCTURES. ALSO NOT A GOOD
RESULT THEREFORE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
NAME IS BLOOM.
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE
ITEM CLERK.
WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLICK WELL CLOSE ROLE. CALVET I.
SIXTY ONE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
FILE ITEM SIXTY NINE IS AB
TWENTY ONE NINETY NINE.
CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE NINETY
NINE BY SOME REMEMBER IRWIN THAT
RELATE TO THE STATE BUDGET.
MISSOURI WHEN YOU MAY OPEN.
BAKER
AB TWENTY ONE NINETY NINE WOULD
REQUIRE THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE TO NOTIFY THE AUTHOR OF
ENACTED LEGISLATION IF THE
DEPARTMENT SUBMITS DRAFT.
BUDGET TRAILER LANGUAGE THAT
WOULD DELAY THE EFFECTIVE DATE
OR MODIFY THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
RECENTLY ENACTED LEGISLATION.
DURING THE CONSIDERATION OF THE
TWENTY SIXTEEN TWENTY SEVENTEEN
BUDGET.
FOR TRAILER BILLS INCLUDED
LANGUAGE SEEKING TO UNDO
LEGISLATION THAT HAD BEEN SIGNED
BY THE GOVERNOR THE PREVIOUS
YEAR. THIS IS UNACCEPTABLE WE
SHOULD AT A MINIMUM RECEIVED
NOTICE OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE TRIES TO
BUREAUCRATICALLY VETO ONE OF OUR
BILLS. THAT THE GOVERNOR HAS
SIGNED INTO LAW I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER ONE SCENE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
QUIRK CORPORAL.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLL TIDE BUT I SIXTY
FIVE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
MEMBERS WERE FILE ITEM NUMBER
SEVENTY AB TWENTY NINE THIRTEEN
CORKERY.
SO WE WILL TWENTY NINE THIRTEEN
BY SOME REMEMBER WOULD NOT
RELATE TO BUILDING PERMITS
DOCTOR WOULD YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTIAL
CONSTRUCTION IS STILL EMERGING
FROM THE WORST ECONOMIC DOWNTURN
IN THE PAST SIXTY YEARS.
WELL HOMEBUILDING CONTINUES THE
MARKETABILITY OF HOME
CONSTRUCTION WITHIN A REGION CAN
CHANGE RAPIDLY PROMPTING
PROJECTS TO TEMPORARILY SLOWDOWN
OR CEASE OPERATION FOR EXTENDED
PERIODS OF TIME. THEIR NUMBER
REASONS FOR THESE DELAYS LOCAL
MARKET CONDITIONS COMMUNITY
REACTIONS AND AVAILABILITY OF
THE.
BUILDING MATERIALS AND LABOR.
ALL OF THESE FACTORS ARE
EXACERBATED IN AREAS IMPACTED BY
NATURAL DISASTERS SUCH AS MY
DISTRICT. THIS IS A ISSUE OF
STATEWIDE CONCERN.
CURRENT LAW ALLOWS BUILDING PILL
PERMIT APPLICATIONS BE VALID FOR
A HUNDRED AND EIGHTY DAYS. WHILE
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS HAVE THE
AUTHORITY TO EXTEND THESE
PERMITS THIS IS OFTEN DONE ON A
CASE BY CASE BASIS CREATING
UNCERTAINTY. TO THE LOCAL
ADMINISTRATOR PROCESS
ADDITIONALLY SOME JURISDICTIONS
HAVE TAKEN SPECIFIC ACTION TO
PROHIBIT THE EXTENSION OF
BUILDING PERMITS REQUIRE THEM TO
RESTART THE ENTIRE APPLICATION
PROCESS AND PAY ADDITIONAL FEES.
AB TWENTY NINE THIRTEEN WHAT A
PROVIDE A PERMIT THAT REMAINS
VALID IF THE WORK ON SITE
AUTHORIZED. BY THE PERMITS
COMMENCED WITHIN THREE YEARS
AFTER THE PERMIT IS WAS WAS
ISSUED ADDITIONALLY THIS BILL
ADDS A FIVE YEAR SUNSET TO
REVIEW ITS IMPACT.
HAVING A PERMIT REMAIN VALID FOR
THREE YEARS IS NOT UNPRECEDENTED
PERMITS FOR MANUFACTURED HOME
HOUSING REMAIN VALID FOR THREE
YEARS. THE LONGSTANDING REASONS
FOR THIS IS TO PROMOTE HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY RECOGNIZING THAT
GOING TO THE END OF THE LOCAL
PERMIT LINE CAN CREATE DELAYS
AND ADDED COSTS.
THIS BILL IS REALLY RECEIVED
UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN
POLICY COMMITTEE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WOULD.
SENIOR DISCLOSURE DEBATE ON THE
ITEM CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE VOTE ON
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLE IN TIME BUT I SIXTY
EIGHT. KNOWS ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
MEMBERS ARE FILE ITEM SEVENTY
ONE AB THIRTY EIGHTY SIX.
CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY EIGHTY SIX
BY SOME REMEMBER KILEY
IMMACULATELY PEOPLE ATTENDANCE.
KILEY.
I THINK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB
THIRTY EIGHTY SIX WHICH RECEIVED
UNANIMOUS SUPPORT IN THE
ASSEMBLY EDUCATION COMMITTEE.
GIVE SPECIFIED STUDENTS ARE
HOMELESS MIGRANT FOSTER AND
BELIEVE YOUTH
A RIGHT TO TRANSFER TO A SCHOOL
DISTRICT THAT IS WILLING TO
ACCEPT THEM.
QUITE SIMPLY AB THIRTY EIGHTY
SIX WOULD ALLOW THESE SOME OF
OUR MOST VULNERABLE STUDENTS
TO ENROLL IN A DIFFERENT SCHOOL
DISTRICT THAN THE ONE THEY'D BE
ASSIGNED TO BECAUSE OF WHERE
THEY LIVE.
HOMELESS MIGRANT FOSTER AND BOYD
YOUTH.
ARE OFTEN THE STUDENTS MOST
DEPRIVED OF THE STABILITY THAT
IS SO IMPORTANT ACADEMIC
SUCCESS.
THIS LACK OF EDUCATIONAL
STABILITY COMPOUNDS THE BURDENS
TRAUMAS AND CHALLENGES THAT
HOMELESS MIGRANT FOSTER AND
BULLIED YOUTH OFTEN FACE.
AB THIRTY EIGHTY SIX WILL
PROVIDE A MUCH NEEDED MEASURE OF
STABILITY BY ALLOWING THESE KIDS
TO ENROLL AND REMAIN IN THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT THAT BEST FITS
THEIR NEEDS.
THE BILL WOULD ALSO SURE THEY
CAN RECEIVE THE TRANSPORTATION
THEY NEED TO GET TO SCHOOL.
THE BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION AYE
AS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR IVA.
THANK YOU MISTER KILEY SEEN NO
DISCUSSION ON THE ITEM.
CLERK LIBERAL. I'M VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE YOUR OWN TIED
ABOUT AYE SIXTY TWO NO ZERO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM
SEVENTY TO PASS A RETAIN.
WE ARE IT FILE ITEM NUMBER
SEVENTY THREE.
THAT IS AB THIRTY TWENTY TWO BY
MISS GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
CLERK WILL READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTY TWENTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GONZALEZ FLETCHER
AN ACCOLADE HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMAS
IS GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
THANK YOU AND GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER SPEAKER AB THIRTY TWENTY
WOULD ALLOW SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO
GRANT A HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATION
DIPLOMA TO PUPIL THAT IS
DEPORTED DURING THEIR SENIOR
YEAR IN HIGH SCHOOL.
STUDENT GETS DEPORTED THEY WILL
FACE JOB AN EDUCATIONAL BARRIERS
WITHOUT A PROPER EDUCATIONAL
CREDENTIAL ESPECIALLY IF THEY DO
NOT SPEAK THE LANGUAGE OR HAVE
ANY CONNECTION TO THEIR COUNTRY
OF ORIGIN.
WE SHOULD STRIP STUDENTS FROM
THEIR FUTURE EVEN IF THEY
UNFORTUNATELY GET DEPORTED BY
THIS ADMINISTRATION.
TO BE CLEAR THIS BILL ONLY GRANT
SCHOOL DISTRICTS DISCRETION
WHETHER NOT GRANT DIPLOMAS TO
HIGH SCHOOL SENIORS THEY'RE IN
GOOD ACADEMIC STANDING AT THE
TIME OF THEIR DEPORTATION. THE
BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION NO KNOWN
OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR MY VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS GONZALEZ FLETCHER
SENIOR DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM.
CORD GLOBAL ROLL-ON MEMBERS FOR
THEIR VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
A CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND
HOW THE NIGHT'S FIFTY SIX.
KNOWS ONE.
THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM
SEVENTY FOUR THROUGH SEVENTY SIX
PASS AND RETAIN.
A. B..
SEVENTY SEVEN.
IS AB TWENTY TWO.
NINETY NINE BY MISTER KANSEN CHU
FOR THE PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS
A CORPORAL READ WITH AMENDMENTS.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TWO NINETY
NINE WITH AMENDMENTS BY SOME
MEMBER KANSEN CHU.
MISTER CHU ON THE AMENDMENTS
CHECK YOUR MISTER SPEAKER SAM
MEMBERS.
I RUSH TO PRETEND AMENDMENT FOR
AB TWENTY TWO NINETEEN I. USED
AMENDMENTS WILL ENSURE NO EFFORT
ARE DUPLICATED. AMENDMENTS
PROVIDE EXEMPTION FOR MATERIALS
TO HAVE ALREADY BEEN FIELD
TESTED. EMAD A STANDARD ASKED UP
AMONG BILL.
AND ALSO CLARIFY EACH MANAGEMENT
CARE PLAN ONLY NEEDS TO DO HAVE
ONE COMMUNITY REVIEW PER
STRUCTURAL LANGUAGE.
AND ALSO SET UP THE ROOM A A
DEADLINE FOR THE REVIEW REVIEW
PROCESS I RECALL ASK FOR YOUR
ARRIVAL.
FAMOUS SHIP.
SEE NO DISCUSSION AND WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE. AYE
OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE AMENDMENTS
ARE ADOPTED THE BILL'S HOW TO
PRINT.
AND BACK ON FILE WORK FILE ITEM
SEVENTY EIGHT AB TWENTY FOUR.
NINETY SIX.
BY MISS GONZALEZ FLETCHER
CORPORAL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FOUR NINETY
SIX.
FLETCHER YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU AB TWENTY FORTY AND
I'M
TWENTY FOUR NINETY SIX
WILL PROTECT PROPERTY SERVICE
WORKERS FROM UNSCRUPULOUS
COMPANIES WHO SEEK TO EVADE
BASIC WORKER PROTECTION LAWS.
SPECIFICALLY THIS BILL ENSURES
THE PROPERTY SERVICE WORKERS ARE
TREATED AS EMPLOYEES AND NOT
MISS CLASSIFIED AS INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS THIS WILL HELP
REDUCE LABOR TRAFFICKING AND
WAGE THEFT. AB TWENTY FOUR
NINETY SIX HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND HAS NO
OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
SEE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THERE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED THIS ADDED
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE THE ROLE ANTI VOTE ICE
FORTY FOUR KNOWS FOR THAT
MEASURE PASSES
.
MEMBERS WHERE FILE ITEM NUMBER
SEVENTY NINE AB TWENTY SEVEN
SIXTY.
BY DR WOULD CORKERY. ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY BY SOME
REMEMBER WOULD NOT RELATE TO
HEALING ARTS.
DOCTOR WOULD YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
AB TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY IS ONE OF
MORE THAN A DOZEN BILLS THAT
WILL. BE APPEAR BEFORE US IN THE
NEXT SEVERAL WEEKS AIMED AT
ADDRESSING THE OPIOID EPIDEMIC
BY NOW MOST OF US KNOW SOME OF
THE DEVASTATING STATISTICS TIED
TO THIS NATIONAL EPIDEMIC.
IN TWO THOUSAND AND SIXTEEN
HUNDRED AND SIXTEEN PEOPLE DIED
EVERY DAY FROM OPIOID RELATED
DRUG OVERDOSES.
TWO POINT ONE MILLION PEOPLE HAD
AN OPIOID DISORDER.
WHAT ELEVEN POINT FIVE MILLION
PEOPLE MISS USE PRESCRIPTION
OPIOIDS THAT ONE BEARS REPEATING
ELEVEN POINT FIVE MILLION
PEOPLE?
FORTY PERCENT OF THE FORTY TWO
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED A TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY OPIOID RELATED
DEATHS WERE ATTRIBUTED TO
OVERDOSING ONCOMMONLY
PRESCRIBED OPIOIDS.
AB TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY IS
DESIGNED TO DO ONE THING SAVE
LIVES.
IT'S DESIGNED TO PROVIDE
PATIENTS WITH THE KNOWLEDGE THAT
THEIR OPIATE PRESCRIPTION PLACES
THEM INTO ONE AT THAT AT RISK
FOR OVERDOSE CATEGORY. THEN
OFFERS TO PUT INTO THEIR HANDS
THE HAND THE HANDS OF THEIR
FAMILY MEMBERS AND FRIENDS THE
SINGLE MOST EFFECTIVE METHOD OF
KEEPING THEM ALIVE SHOULD THE
EXPERIENCE AN OPIATE OVERDOSE.
IT REQUIRES A PRESCRIBERS HAVE A
DISCUSSION WITH THEIR PATIENTS
WHO MEET NATIONALLY RECOGNIZED
DEFINITIONS OF AT RISK FOR
OVERDOSE. CRITERIA ABOUT THE
RISK OF OVERDOSE AND OFFER THEM.
A LIFESAVING PRESCRIPTION FOR
NALOXONE HYDROCHLORIDE THE LOCKS
ON IS AN OPIOID ANTAGONISTIC
ACTS IMMEDIATELY UPON
ADMINISTRATION TO REVERSE THE
DID THE AFFECTS OF OPIOIDS.
LAAKSO MAY BE ADMINISTERED
EITHER NASALLY OR THROUGH AN
INJECTION.
THREE OTHER STATES HAVE SIMILAR
LAWS A NUMBER OF STATES HAVE
BILLS PENDING AND AT LEAST
ELEVEN NATIONAL ORGANIZATIONS
INCLUDING THE CDC. AND THE AMA
RECOMMEND CHO PRESCRIBING A LOT
SO WITHOUT RISK OAK
PRESCRIPTIONS.
FINALLY WITH EMERGENCY RELIEF
ROOM VISITS COSTS AVERAGING
TWENTY SIX HUNDRED DOLLARS
HOSPITALIZATION ADMIN AT
ADMISSIONS COST AVERAGING NINE
THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED DOLLARS IN
ICU ADMISSIONS RUNNING AT AN
AVERAGE OF NINETY TWO THOUSAND
DOLLARS.
A CO PRESCRIBING IN THE LOCKS ON
COULD IN ADDITION TO SAVING
LIVES AND REVERSING OVERDOSES.
REDUCE HOSPITALIZATIONS AND THE
ASSOCIATED COSTS RESULTING IN AN
OVERALL COST SAVINGS TO THE
SYSTEM.
IN CLOSING THIS BILL IS AN
IMPORTANT STEP TOWARDS REDUCING
THE NUMBER OF OVERDOSES BY
EDUCATION EDUCATING PATIENTS
ABOUT THEIR RISKS.
INCREASING THE RATE OF SURVIVAL
OF INDIVIDUALS WHO EXPERIENCE AN
OVERDOSE
IT'S SIMPLE IT WORKS AND IT
SAVES LIVES. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WOOD MISTER
HARPER. YOU'RE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I DON'T THINK THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD ON
THIS IN COMPANION LEGISLATION
THAT'S BIPARTISAN ATTACKING THIS
ISSUE. I IN A STRAIGHT IT IT OF
WAY IS INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT. I
IN FACT I LURK FIRST LEARNED OF
THIS EPIDEMIC OUT WHEN I WAS A
SCHOOL BOARD TRUSTEE AND I SAW A
A VERY YOUNG MAN.
WHO WAS HIS LIFE HAD BEEN TAKEN
UP BY OPIOIDS I PUT SOME PEOPLE
THOUGHT IT CAN'T HAPPEN HERE BUT
IT IS HERE THROUGHOUT URBAN
AREAS SUBURBAN AREAS?
AS WELL AS RURAL AREAS OF THE
STATE AND IT'S INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT AYE THAT WE FOCUS ON
THIS ISSUE AYE AND ALSO.
AYE MY HOPE IS THAT WE CAN COME
TOGETHER AYE IN ALSO TACKLE THE
ISSUE OF SOBER LIVING HOMES
WHICH IS A BY PRODUCT OF THE
OPEN AT EMIC EPIDEMIC. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I MISTER SPEAKER I FOR
A STRONGLY URGE A VOTE IN FAVOR
OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU MISTER HARPER.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
CLERK LOCAL ROLL-ON MEMBERS.
ROSARIO VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSER ROLE AND TELL
A LOT ICE FIFTY EIGHT.
NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES
MEMBERS WERE GOING TO MOVE BACK
IN THE FILE TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
SIXTY FOUR. THIS IS AB NINETEEN
HUNDRED BY MR PEROT THIS IS FILE
ITEM SIXTY FOUR THE CLERK WILL
READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL NINETEEN HUNDRED
BY SOME REMEMBER PEROT ACCOLADE
TO ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT. MISTER
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB
NINETEEN HUNDRED IS A LOCAL
PROGRAM THAT ALLOWS CITIES OR
COUNTIES THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PARTNER WITH MANUFACTURING
FACILITIESTO INVEST LONG TERM
IN THEIR COMMUNITIES. BY
OFFERING PROPERTY TAX REBATES
FOR UP TO FIFTEEN YEARS
EXTENDING THE CALIFORNIA
INVESTMENT INCENTIVE PROGRAM
OFFERS A CHANCE TO BUILD LOCAL
COMMITTEE SUPPORT. FOR
ATTRACTING AND RETAINING A
BUSINESS CALIFORNIA MUST ALWAYS
REMEMBER THAT IN TODAY'S GLOBAL
ECONOMY LOCATION IS NOT
PERMANENT. BUT A CHOICE WE NEED
TO MAKE THAT CHOICE EASIER TO
LOCATE BUSINESSES CONTRACTS A
PRODUCT INVESTMENT HERE AB
NINETEEN HUNDRED IS ONE WAY TO
HELP INCREASE CALIFORNIA'S
ABILITY TO ATTRACT. AND RETAIN
THESE CAPITAL INTENSIVE AND HIGH
WAGE JOBS THANK YOU AND RESPECT
FLASH DRIVE OF.
THANK YOU MISTER BRO SEEING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE ITEM
CLERK LOCAL ROLL-ON MEMBERS HER
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLL TALIBAN AYE SIXTY TWO
NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES
MEMBERS BACK IN FILE ORDER.
FILE ITEM EIGHTY IS AB TWENTY
NINE EIGHTEEN BY MR HOLDEN THE
CORPORATE ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
NINE EIGHTEEN BY SOME REMEMBER
HOLDEN THAT ACCOLADE TO
VEHICLES.
MISTER HOLDEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY NINE
EIGHTEEN WOULD REQUIRE THE
DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR VEHICLES TO
INCLUDE IN THE CALIFORNIA
DRIVER'S HANDBOOK INFORMATION
REGARDING A PERSON CIVIL RIGHTS
DURING A TRAFFIC STOP.
THE DRIVER'S HANDBOOK INCLUDES
SUGGESTIONS ON HOW TO CONDUCT
ONESELF DURING A STOP. BUT
STOPPED SHORT OF STATING THE
RIGHTS OF THE DRIVER AND WHAT TO
DO IF THE SITUATION IS
ESCALATING.
BEING INFORMED OF THESE RIGHTS
ARE CRITICAL IN SITUATIONS THAT
CAN QUICKLY GO FROM CALM TO
WORSE.
AB TWENTY NINE EIGHTEEN STILL
ADDRESS THE EXTENT AND
LIMITATIONS OF A POLICE
OFFICER'S AUTHORITY. DURING A
TRAFFIC STOP AND THE LEGAL
RIGHTS OF THE DRIVERS AND
PASSENGERS.
THIS INFORMATION WILL BE
DEVELOPED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
MOTOR VEHICLES AFTER CONSULTING
WITH STAKEHOLDERS. IN THE PUBLIC
SAFETY AND CIVIL JUSTICE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER HOLDEN.
SEE NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THE ITEM CLERK LOCAL ROLE.
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE ON
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE YOUR OWN TIED ABOUT ICE
FIFTY.
NO ZERO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
WE'RE PASSING AND RETAINING ON
FILE ITEM EIGHTY ONE.
WE ARE AT FILE ITEM EIGHTY TWO
AB THIRTY ONE SIXTY EIGHT BY
MISS RUBIO CLERK WILL READ.
SO WE WILL THIRTY ONE SIXTY
EIGHT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER RUBIO
AND ACCOLADES OUTDOOR
ADVERTISING.
THIS RUBIO YOU MAY OPEN THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
A. B. THIRTY ONE SIXTY EIGHT
GIVE CITIES FLEXIBILITY TO READ
RELOCATE. PERMITTED SCIENCE
OUTSIDE A MINISTER OF MUNICIPAL
BOUNDARIES. ONTO SECTIONS OF
LANDSCAPE FREEWAY WHILE STILL
CONFORMING TO STATE AND FEDERAL
REGULATIONS AND NOT ADDING ANY
MORE NEW SIGNAGE ON CALIFORNIA
HIGHWAYS.
SPECIFICALLY A. B. THIRTY ONE
SIXTY EIGHT WOULD CREATE A MORE
SPECIFIC DEFINITION OF THE
LANDSCAPE FREEWAYS.
GIVE CITIES A PATHWAY TO RELOOK
RELOCATED PERMITTED EXISTING
FINE. TO AND FROM ONE LOCATION
TO ANOTHER.
AND ALLOW EXISTING DISPLAYS TO
BE CONVERTED TO MODERN DIGITAL
SCIENCE. IF A CITY DESIRES IT.
THEY WERE COMPLETE LOCAL
CONTROL.
I'M SORRY COMPLETE LOCAL CONTROL
WILL BE MAINTAINED AND ANY
REALLY RELOCATED DISPLAYS Y.
HAVE TO. FULLY COMPLY WITH ALL
OF THE SECTIONS OF THE OUTDOOR
ADVERTISING ACT.
SUBJECT TO CALTRANS REVIEW AND
APPROVAL.
THIS BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION NEXT
NEGLIGIBLE COST AND HAS RECEIVED
UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS RUBIO.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE ITEM CLERICAL OVER THE
ROLL-ON VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE THE ROLL TIDE OF AND I
SIXTY TWO.
NOS ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
PASS RETAIN OF FILE ITEM EIGHTY
THREE WE'VE DISPENSED WITH FILE
ITEM EIGHTY FOUR.
IT BRINGS US TO FILE ITEM EIGHTY
FIVE ACR TO THIRTY FIVE BY
DOCTOR ARAMBULA CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
TO THIRTY FIVE BY SOME REMEMBER
ARAMBULA RELATIVE TO TROM
INFORMED AWARENESS DAY. DOCTOR
ARAMBULA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
ACR TO THIRTY FIVE DESIGNATES
MAY TWENTY SECOND AS TRAUMA
INFORMED AWARENESS DAY IN
CALIFORNIA.
THIS WILL BE IN CONJUNCTION WITH
THE NATIONAL TRAUMA INFORMED
AWARENESS DAY.
THIS DESIGNATION IMPACTS THE
TRAUMA AND IMPORTANCE OF
PREVENTION AND COMMUNITY
RESILIENCE THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA.
CURRENTLY FORTY TWO PERCENT OF
CALIFORNIANS.
CHILDREN AND SIXTY ONE PERCENT
OF CALIFORNIA ADULTS HAVE
EXPERIENCED ONE OR MORE ADVERSE
CHILDHOOD EXPERIENCES MORE
COMMONLY REFERRED TO AS ACES.
ACES ARE STRESSFUL OR TRAUMATIC
EXPERIENCES THAT INCLUDE ABUSE
NEGLECT RACISM AND HOUSEHOLD
INSTABILITY THAT ARE OFTENTIMES
RECOGNIZED AS A PROXY FOR TOXIC
STRESS.
WHICH CAN AFFECT THE BRAIN AND
BODY DEVELOPMENT AND IF NOT
ADDRESSED CAN LEAD TO MENTAL AND
EMOTIONAL AND PHYSICAL HEALTH
CONSEQUENCES. AFFECTING HEALTH
AND WELLBEING ACROSS THE
LIFESPAN OF A PERSON.
ACES ARE DETERMINANT OF THE
PUBLIC HEALTH PROBLEMS IN
CALIFORNIA.
SUCH AS HEART DISEASE SUBSTANCE
ABUSE AND MENTAL ILLNESS.
DETRIMENTAL EFFECTS.
CAN BE BUFFERED BY BUILDING
RESILIENCY AND PROMOTING
PROTECTIVE FACTORS IN A CHILD'S
LIFE THROUGH EARLY INTERVENTION.
TRAUMA INFORMED CARE IS AN
APPROACH THAT CAN.
BRING GREATER UNDERSTANDING AND
MORE EFFECTIVE WAYS TO PREVENT
IDENTIFYING SUPPORT AND TO
SERVE.
CHILDREN ADULTS FAMILIES AND
COMMUNITIES
AFFECTED BY ACES
TRAUMA ADVERSITY AND TOXIC
STRESS.
BY ADOPTING TRAUMA INFORMED
APPROACHES WE CAN BUILD
RESILIENCY AND PROMOTE
PROTECTIVE FACTORS IN ALL
SECTORS OF OUR SOCIETY.
I URGE MY FELLOW MEMBERS TO JOIN
ME AND HIGHLIGHTING THE IMPACT
OF DRAMA. AND THE IMPORTANCE OF
PREVENTION AND COMMUNITY
RESILIENCE THROUGH TRAUMA
INFORMED CARE BY SUPPORTING.
ACR TO THIRTY FIVE.
MISTER SPEAKER I WOULD LIKE THE
FIRST ROLL OPENED FOR CO
AUTHORS.
THANK YOU DOCTOR ARAMBULA.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE ITEM THE AUTHORS ASSN THE
FIRST WILL BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS
CORPORAL OF THE ROLE.
THIS IS A CO AUTHORS ADDING ON
TO THE RESOLUTION
A CO AUTHORS ADDING ON WE SEE
OUR TO THIRTY FIVE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE THE ROLE THERE SIXTY SIX
CO AUTHORS AT IT WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION ALL THOSE
IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAME.
YES HAVE AT THE RESOLUTION.
IS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WERE FILE ITEM EIGHTY
SIX.
EACH OUR SIXTY TWO.
BY MISTER LACKEY CORKERY.
HOUSE RESOLUTION SIXTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LACKEY RELATIVE
TO WE CARD AWARENESS MONTH.
MISTER LACKEY YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
PICTURE SIXTY TWO CALLS FOR THE
RECOGNITION. OF THE MONTH OF
SEPTEMBER AS WE CARD AWARENESS
MONTH.
WE CARD IS A PROGRAM THAT TRAINS
AND EDUCATES RETAILERS OF
TOBACCO. ALCOHOL
CIGARETTES
PAPER PRODUCTS ANOTHER AGE
RESTRICTED PRODUCTS TO COMPLY
WITH THEIR RESPECTIVE STATES
LEGAL PURCHASING AGE.
WITH A LARGE NUMBER OF
CONVENIENCE STORES AND IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA BEING SINGLE
OWNER.
AND OPERATORS THESE INDEPENDENT
OWNERS AND OPERATORS RELY ON
PROGRAMS SUCH AS WE CARD. TO
REMAIN A COMPLIANCE IS THEY
SERVE. AND INTER GOAL FAMILY
BUSINESS IN THEIR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES.
THE TWENTY SIXTEEN THIS
LEGISLATION I'M SORRY THIS
LEGISLATURE ARE. DECREASED THE
LEGAL PURCHASING AGE OF TOBACCO
PRODUCTS FROM EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY
ONE YEARS OF AGE.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO LOCAL
INDEPENDENT RETAILERS HAVE THE
PROPER EDUCATION AND TOOLS TO
HONOR THIS CHANGE IN STATUTE.
IT'S ARE SIXTY TWO PROMOTES
RESPONSIBLE RETAILERS FOR
HONORING THE LEGAL PURCHASING
AGE OF THE STATE AND I WOULD
LIKE TO OPEN THE FIRST ROLE.
BECAUSE THERE'S.
THANK YOU MISTER LACKEY
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE AT IN THE FIRST ROW WILL BE
OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE HOUSE
RESOLUTE.
CLERK LOCAL ROLL-ON THIS IS FOR
CO AUTHORS.
THIS IS CO AUTHORS
ON THE HOUSE RESOLUTION.
THE CLERK.
AS FOR CO AUTHORS THE CLERK WILL
CLOSE ROLE THERE ARE SIXTY NINE
CO AUTHORS ADDED WITHOUT
OBJECTION.
A VOICE VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
I OPPOSE IN A.
THE AYES HAVE IT. THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED.
FILE ITEM EIGHTY SEVEN IS HR ONE
EIGHT BY MR LOW CORKERY.
HOUSE RESOLUTION ONE AWAY BY
SOME WOMEN BELOW AND OTHERS
RELATIVES HARVEY MILK DAY.
MISTER LOW YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS I'M HERE TODAY
TO PRESENT EACH ARE. ONE WAY
WHICH RECOGNIZES THE
CONTRIBUTIONS OF HARVEY MILK TO
THE LGBT CIVIL RIGHTS MOVEMENT.
TO THE POLITICAL HISTORY OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE POLITICAL
LANDSCAPE. IN THE WORLD.
HARVEY MILK.
BECAME A COMMUTE LEADER FOUNDING
THE CASTRO VALLEY ASSOCIATION OF
LOCAL MERCHANTS
HE RAN UNSUCCESSFULLY FOR PUBLIC
OFFICE TWICE BEFORE. BEING
ELECTED TO REPRESENT DISTRICT
FIVE ON THE CITY BOARDS OF
SUPERVISORS IN SAN FRANCISCO HE
WAS THE FIRST OPENLY GAY MAN.
TO BE ELECTED TO PROMINENT
POLITICAL OFFICE IN THE UNITED
STATES.
AS WELL NO HE WAS MURDERED BY
POLITICAL OPPONENT AT CITY HALL
SHORTLY AFTER.
.
A PERPETRATOR.
AT IN THE SITTING COUNTY OF SAN
FRANCISCO PLEASE JOIN ME IN
RECOGNIZING THE. LANDMARK CIVIL
RIGHTS WORK OF HARVEY MILK I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
YOU MISTER LOWE.
MISTER DAVID CHIU YOUR RECOGNIZE
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
COLLEAGUES ON BEHALF OF THE API
CAUCUS AS WELL AS AS A SAN
FRANCISCAN I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS MEASURE. CELEBRATING
ARGUABLY THE MOST FAMOUS ICONIC
FIGURE FOR MY CITY.
HARVEY MILK WAS THE FIRST OPENLY
GAY ELECTED OFFICIAL IN
CALIFORNIA HE SERVED ON SAN
FRANCISCO'S BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS.
HE ALSO RAN FOR THE ASSEMBLY
SEAT THAT I'M HONORED TO HOLD.
AT A TIME WHEN SOMEONE COULD BE
FIRED ARRESTED OR KILLED SIMPLY
BECAUSE WHO THEY LOVED.
HARVEY MILK SHOWED THE WORLD
THAT BEING LOUD AND PROUD WAS
THE ONLY WAY TO FIGHT AGAINST
THE LIES AND DISCRIMINATION
AGAINST LGBT COMMUNITY.
HIS WORK TRULY TRANSFORMED OUR
COUNTRY'S POLITICAL LANDSCAPE.
HE DEDICATED HIMSELF TO WORKING
WITH GROUPS WHO'D BEEN
MARGINALIZED LEFT OUT OF THE
POLITICAL PROCESS IN OUR CITY.
INCLUDING SINGLE MOTHERS LOW
INCOME RESIDENTS AND THE AFRICAN
AMERICAN AND API COMMUNITIES.
AS WE CELEBRATE WHAT WOULD HAVE
BEEN HARVEY'S EIGHTY EIGHTH
BIRTHDAY THIS PAST WEEK WE MUST
RECOGNIZE NOT ONLY THE
DISCRIMINATION. CONTINUE TO
CONTINUE TO BE FACED BY SO MANY
OTHER BE TO CALIFORNIANS BUT
ALSO OUR OWN POWER TO CREATE
EQUALITY AND LIBERTY FOR ALL.
THERE MAY BE SO MUCH TO DO BUT
WE CAN GET IT DONE AS HARVEY
WOULD HAVE SAID. YOU GOTTA GIVE
THEM HOPE.
ESTHER BERMAN YOUR RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I HAVE
THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE
JEWISH CAUCUS ARISE IN SUPPORT
OF HR ONE AT ONE OO EIGHT AND
JOIN WITH ALL WHO CELEBRATE. AND
COMMEMORATE THE PIONEERING LIFE
AND CAREER OF HARVEY MILK.
HARVEY MILK OPEN DOORS BROKE
DOWN BARRIERS AND SERVE AS A
BEACON FOR COUNTLESS LGBT YOUTH
WHO MIGHT NOT OTHERWISE HAVE
CONSIDERED PUBLIC SERVICE.
ALL YOUNG PEOPLE HESAID
REGARDLESS OF SEXUAL ORIENTATION
OR IDENTITY DESERVE A SAFE AND
SUPPORTIVE ENVIRONMENT IN WHICH
TO ACHIEVE THEIR FULL POTENTIAL.
WE AS A STATE MAY NOT OF REACH
OUR FULL POTENTIAL YET. BUT
WE'RE MUCH CLOSER THAN WE WERE
IN NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT. AND
IN NO SMALL PART. WE HAVE HARVEY
MILK TO THINK FOR THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THING IS BERMAN MR HOLDING YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS I STAND
IN SUPPORT.
OF HR ONE AWAY.
HARVEY MILK WAS THE FIRST OPENLY
GAY MAN TO BE ELECTED. TO PUBLIC
OFFICE IN A MAJOR CITY UNITED
STATES.
DURING HIS LIFE ARMY MILK WORK
ON WALL STREET SERVED IN THE
UNITED STATES NAVY.
WORKED AS A THEATER PRODUCER ARM
WAS A PROMINENT COMMUNITY LEADER
IN THE CASTRO NEIGHBORHOOD OF
SAN FRANCISCO.
WHILE SERVING ON THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND SAN FRANCISCO
MILK WORK TIRELESSLY TO IMPROVE
THE LIVES OF THE LGBT
COMMUNITIES.
NO BECAUSE PIVOTAL IN DEFEATING
PROPOSITION SIX.
WHICH WOULD HAVE BANNED GAYS AND
LESBIANS LESBIANS FROM TEACHING
AND PUBLIC SCHOOLS.
HARVEY MILK CALL FOR ALL
MINORITIES TO BAND TOGETHER AND
ADVOCATES FOR EQUALITY IN THE
STAND IN UNITY AGAINST
OPPRESSION OF ALL FORMS.
HARVEY MILK WAS MURDERED IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT
AFTER-YEARS OF BEING AT A
PROMINENT
LEADER FOR LGBT RIGHTS.
HARVEY NOTES WORK CHANGE LIVES
FOR MANY PEOPLE ACROSS
CALIFORNIA AND IS LEGACY
CONTINUES TO INSPIRE ALL OF US
TO BE FEARLESS IN PURSUIT. OF
JUSTICE
AND IN BEING OURSELVES.
AS CHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS I'M
PROUD TO SUPPORT HR ONE AWAIT
AND URGE YOUR SUPPORT AS WELL.
THANK YOU MISTER HOLDEN.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL.
DISCUSSION ON THE RESOLUTION THE
AUTHORS ASKING THAT THE FIRST
ROLE BE OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS THIS IS CO AUTHORS ON HR
ONE WAIT THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS
ADDING ON TO THE RESOLUTION.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
A CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLE THERE ARE FORTY
THREE COAUTHORS AT ON THE
RESOLUTION AND WITHOUT OBJECTION
WE MAY TAKE A VOICE VOTE.
ON THE HOUSE RESOLUTION ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE. AYE
OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO CONSENT
CALENDAR.
THE DOES ANY MEMBER WISH TO
REMOVE AN ITEM FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE THE
CLERK WILL READ THE SECOND DAY
CONSENT CALENDAR SO WE WILL
THIRTY TO THIRTY NINE BY THE
COMMITTEE ON ELECTIONS AND
REDISTRICTING ACCOLADES
ELECTIONS.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
THIS IS THE CONSENT CALENDAR ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO GO.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
THIS IS THE CONSENT CALENDAR
MEMBERS ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT
OF A.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ALL AYE SIXTY SEVEN AT NO
ZERO THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS
ADOPTED.
MEMBERS THE.
HOLD ON
AVERAGE WE'RE GOING TO BE
ENTERTAINING VOTE CHANGES FROM
YOUR DESK AT THIS TIME IF
MEMBERS HAVE OF CHANGES.
MISTER CALDERON.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MISTER
GIPSON I AM GOING TO BE
CHANGING.
MY VOTE ON FILE ITEM FOURTEEN AB
TWENTY ONE EIGHTY FIVE TWO FROM
NO TO AYE.
VOTE CHANGE CALDERON ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY ONE EIGHTY FIVE NO
TO AYE
.
MEMBERS THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS
WERE GRANTED PRIOR PERMISSION.
SPEAK ON ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
MEMBERS PLEASE NOW WE WILL NOT
BE LEFT IN A QUORUM CALL AT THIS
TIME. WE WILL NOT BE LIFTING A
QUORUM CALL THIS TIME.
THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS WERE
GRANTED PRIOR PERMISSION TO
SPEAK ON AND THE CHAIRMAN A
MEMORY.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS.
WE ARE ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
MR KILEY.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR A
GERMAN IN MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
IT IS WITH GREAT SADNESS AND A
DEEP SENSE OF LOSS.
BUT I ASK THE ASSEMBLY TO
ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY.
OF JOSHUA COURSE AND.
JOSH WAS ENGAGED TO KIM NELSON.
AND WAS A DEVOTED FATHER TO
THREE CHILDREN.
ANTHONY DEVON AND ARIANNA.
JOSH WORK AS A MANAGER FOR
WALGREENS IN ROSEDALE AS A YOUNG
EXECUTIVE. WHO WORKED TIRELESSLY
TIRELESSLY TO SUPPORT HIS STORE
EMPLOYEES WILL MAINTAINING AS
MUCH TIME? AS HE COULD WITH HIS
FAMILY.
JOSH WAS A LOVE FOR HIS
COMMITMENT AN ACTIVE LEADERSHIP
IN THE COMMUNITY.
AS THE HEAD FOOTBALL COACH OF OJ
V..
JOSHUA VOLUNTEERED COUNTLESS
HOURS
TO ENSURE HIS TEAM'S SUCCESS.
HE COACHED YOUTH WALK FOOTBALL
FOR TWO YEARS.
BEFORE LEADING A TACKLE FOOTBALL
TEAM IN TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN.
THAT WE TAUGHT THE IMPORTANCE
IMPORTANCE OF SPORTSMANSHIP OVER
WINNING. JOSH LED HIS TEAM TO
IMPRESSIVE VICTORIES IN HIS LAST
SEASON AND I'VE EVEN LEARNED
FROM HIS FAMILY THAT IN THE
COURSE OF FOUR YEARS HE TURNED
THE RECORD FROM. OH IN NINE TO
NINE AND ONE WITH THE ONLY LOSS
COMING IN THE CHAMPIONSHIP GAME.
JOSH WILL BE GREATLY MISSED BY
HIS FAMILY FRIENDS AND HIS TEAM.
HE'LL BE REMEMBERED FOR HIS
CONTRIBUTIONS TO THE OAKMONT
JUNIOR VIKINGS AND THE ROSEVILLE
COMMUNITY.
HE TOUCHED THE LIVES OF MANY
MANY PEOPLE AND THAT IMPACT WILL
BE FELT IN OUR COMMUNITY FOR A
LONG LONG TIME TO COME.
MISTER SPEAKER I ASK THAT TODAY
THE CALIFORNIA STATE ASSEMBLY.
A JOURNEY THE MEMORY OF JOSHUA
COURSES.
THANK YOU MISTER KILEY.
MS CABALLERO. YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR CHAIRMAN IN MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
TODAY I RISE TO ADJOURN IN THE
MEMORY OF RECOUNT TOLL PRESIDENT
AND CHIEF EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF
PANAMA IN AND TOLD. THE LARGEST
LETTUCE AND VEGETABLE PRODUCER
IN THE SALINAS VALLEY.
BEFORE TAMERA AND MANTLE WRECK
WAS VICE PRESIDENT A BUT AND
TOLL INCORPORATED WHICH
EVENTUALLY BECAME A DIVISION TO
WHAT IS KNOWN TODAY AS DOLE
FRESH VEGETABLES.
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY TWO MISTER
AND TALL AND HIS FATHER FORMED
KIND OF MARIN AND TOLD. WITH THE
TEMORA FAMILY.
RICK HELD THE POSITION OF
PRESIDENT AND PRINCIPAL OF THE
COMPANY SINCE ITS CREATION AND
BECAME ITS C. E. O.. IN TWO
THOUSAND AND THREE.
MISTER RANDALL HAS BEEN
RECOGNIZED AS A TRUE PRODUCE
INDUSTRY ICON.
THE SUCCESS ATTENDED MARIN
MANTLE CAN BE ATTRIBUTED NOT
ONLY TO MISTER AND PUTS
INNOVATION BUT HIS FEARLESS
LEADERSHIP.
HIS PERSISTENT DRIVE TO LEAVE
HIS COMPANY TO BECOME THE
NATION'S PREMIER INDEPENDENT
PRODUCE GROW OR PRODUCE PRODUCE
GROWER SHIPPER AND DISTRIBUTOR.
DESPITE BEING A VISIONARY HE
NEVER LOST SIGHT OF THE
ESSENTIAL ELEMENTS OF HIS
BUSINESS
CUSTOMERS. GROWERS AND EMPLOYEES
MR ANTON'S RESPECT AND
DEDICATION TO HIS EMPLOYEES WENT
BEYOND THOSE OF A TRADITIONAL
EMPLOYEE. IN TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN HE LAUNCHED A HOUSING
PROJECT FOR EIGHT HUNDRED FARM
OF HIS FARM WORKER EMPLOYEES AT
SPRECKELS CROSSING. FOR THIS HE
RECEIVED THE BEN HELLER AWARD
FOR LEADERSHIP AND COURAGE FROM
THE CENTER FOR COMMUNITY
ADVOCACY.
A FARM WORKER HOUSING ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION.
IN FEBRUARY OF LAST YEAR TEMERIN
MANTLE TRANSITIONED INTO AN
EMPLOYEE STOCK OWNERSHIP PLAN.
ALLOWING EMPLOYEES TO BE PARTIAL
OWNERS OF THE COMPANY.
RICK DID NOT JUST CARE FOR ITS
WORKERS BUT HIS COMMUNITY HE
SERVED MANY LEADERSHIP POSITIONS
WITHIN THE FAMILY ANTEL FAMILY
OF COMPANIES. CHARITIES AND
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS HE
SERVED AS CHAIRMAN OF THE
MONTEREY COUNTY WATER RESOURCE
AGENCY AND SERVED ON NUMEROUS
BOARDS INCLUDING THE ICEBERG
LETTUCE RESEARCH. BOARD
EARTHBOUND FARMS.
READY PACKED PRODUCE AND THE CAL
POLY COLLEGE OF AGRICULTURE
ADVISORY COUNCIL TO NAME JUST A
FEW.
MR AND AND TOLLS WORK HAS NOT
FOUND IN RECOGNIZED.
OVER THE DECADES HE HAS BEEN
RECOGNIZED WITH MANY AWARDS
INCLUDING THE PACKER PRODUCE MAN
OF THE YEAR. AND HE WAS
COMMEMORATED BY THE SALINAS
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE FOR HIS
WORKS AND EFFORTS IN THE
COMMUNITY.
IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN RICK AND
TOLD AND HIS WIFE TONYA AND TOLD
RECEIVED THE UNITED FRESH
PRODUCE ASSOCIATION. LIFETIME
ACHIEVEMENT AWARD FOR THE
CONTRIBUTIONS TO THE INDUSTRY.
DESPITE A FRUITFUL CAREER MISTER
AND CLOSE MOST IMPORTANT LEGACY
WAS HIS FAMILY.
IN FACT ONE OF HIS PROUDEST
PERSONAL ACCOMPLISHMENT WAS
WORKING ALONGSIDE HIS SONS BRIAN
AND JEFF.
RECOUNT LA SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE
OF SEVENTEEN YEARS TONYA.
CHILDREN GRANDCHILDREN AND HIS
MOTHER SU ANTEL.
RICK HAS BEEN AN AMAZING ROLE
MODEL FOR THE COMMUNITY PAVING
THE WAY TO SUCCESS FOR SO MANY
AND HIS LEGACY WILL LIVE
FOREVER.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT THE
CALIFORNIA STATE.
ASSEMBLY ADJOURNED IN THE MID
MEMORY EVER CATTLE.
THANK YOU MISS CABALLERO.
MISTER STEINORTH YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
TODAY I'D LIKE TO ADJOURN IN THE
MEMORY OF KATHLEEN BANKS.
OUR FRIEND A COMMUNITY LEADER
KATHY PASSED.
SURROUNDED BY HER FAMILY ON MAY
THIRD TWENTY EIGHTEEN AT THE AGE
OF SEVENTY NINE.
SHE WAS MARRIED TO JOSEPH DEAN
BANKS FOR JUST OVER SIXTY YEARS
TO GET THAT THEY HAD FOUR
CHILDREN. TEN GRANDCHILDREN AND
FIFTEEN GREAT GRAND CHILDREN
WITH ANOTHER ONE ON THE WAY.
THEY ALSO CONSIDER THEMSELVES OF
MOM AND POP TO OVER SIX HUNDRED
BOYS THROUGH THE EDDIE LEE HOMES
FOR YOU. WHERE THEY ACTIVELY
SERVED UNDERSERVED CHILDREN FOR
FORTY FOUR YEARS?
KATHY LEFT HER FAMILY COMMUNITY
SO MUCH TODAY DEDICATED HER LIFE
TO IT.
ALONG WITH RAISING HER OWN
FAMILY HER HEART WAS ALWAYS SENT
ON HELPING OTHERS AND BECAUSE OF
THAT HER LIST OF SERVICE TO OUR
COMMUNITY IS EXTRAORDINARY.
SHE SERVED AS A SCHOOL BOARD
MEMBER FOR NEARLY TWENTY FIVE
YEARS.
CO FOUNDED THE FONTANA BOYS AND
GIRLS CLUB AND BECAME AN
ESSENTIAL MEMBER OF THE BOYS AND
GIRLS CLUB BOARD OF DIRECTORS.
WE WERE LUCKY TO HAVE KATHY
HONOR EDUCATION ADVISORY
COMMITTEE WHERE SHE SHARED HER
WISDOM AND EXPERIENCES.
SHE WORKED TIRELESSLY TO IMPROVE
THE LIVES AND EDUCATION OF OUR
CHILDREN. AND IS TRULY AN
INSTITUTION IN THE INLAND
EMPIRE.
OUR COMMUNITY GRIEVES THE LOSS
OF HER KINDNESS AND OUTSTANDING
LEADERSHIP.
HER MEMORY WILL LIVE ON IN OUR
HEARTS.
NAMED IN HER HONOR KATHY BEINGS
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL IN NORTHERN
FONTANA WILL SERVICE A LASTING
REMINDER OF HER DEDICATION TO
OUR COMMUNITY.
COLLEAGUES ON BEHALF OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA ASSEMBLY
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A CHURNING IN
THE MEMORY IF KATHLEEN THINKS.
THANK YOU MISTER STEINORTH AND
MS RAY HAS ALSO ON THIS
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
TODAY I TO RISE TO ADJOURN IN
THE MEMORY OF KATHLEEN KATHY
BINKS.
A RESIDENT AND LONGTIME SCHOOL
BOARD MEMBER OF THE CITY OF
FONTANA IN MY DISTRICT.
KATHY WILL BE REMEMBERED FOR HER
ADVOCACY ON BEHALF OF CHILDREN
AND THE QUALITY EDUCATION.
BEGAN WITH THE WORK OF KATHY AND
HER HUSBAND DEAN WHEN THEY TOOK
AT RISK CHILDREN INTO THEIR
FAMILY OWNED. EDDIE LEE HOME FOR
BOYS IN NORTH MONTANA.
ASSUMING THE RESPONSIBILITY AND
WORK GUARANTEEING THE WELLBEING
OF HUNDREDS OF YOUNG MEN OVER
THE COURSE OF DECADES.
I WAS AS A RESULT OF THIS WORK
SHE BECAME ACTIVELY INVOLVED IN
EDUCATIONAL ISSUES WITHIN THE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS WHERE SHOULD
CHALLENGE THE STATUS QUO. ON
BEHALF OF THE STUDENTS TO
ADVOCATE FOR THE BETTERMENT OF
FONTANA'S EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM.
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY SEVEN CATHY
WAS ELECTED TO THE FONTANA
SCHOOL BOARD AND SHE REMAINED
THERE IS A BOARD AS A BOARD
MEMBER FOR NEARLY A QUARTER
CENTURY. SERVING MULTIPLE STINTS
AS BOARD PRESIDENT.
KATHY WAS AN INSTITUTION IN
FONTANA SO MUCH SO THAT IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN THE DISTRICT
NAMED AN ELEMENTARY SCHOOL IN
HER HONOR.
SHE WILL BE REMEMBERED BY HER
FRIENDS FAMILY AND OTHER LOVED
ONES AS AN INDIVIDUAL DEDICATED
TO THE PRINCIPLES OF FAITH.
FAMILY AND COMMUNITY.
I JOIN IN REQUESTING THAT THE
CALIFORNIA ASSEMBLY ADJOURNED IN
MEMORY OF KATHY BANKS.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MS REYES.
MISS RUBIO YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR GERMAN MEMBER.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I
RISE TODAY TO REQUEST THAT THE
ASSEMBLY ADJOURNED IN THE MEMORY
OF MISTER CLINT OLIVER NIXON.
WHO PASSED AWAY ON MAY FIRST TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN AT THE AGE OF
NINETY SIX?
DURING THE GREAT TO GREAT
DEPRESSION MISTER NIXON AND HIS
FAMILY RELOCATED TO CALIFORNIA.
AND MOVED IN WITH HIS
GRANDPARENTS WHO LIVED ON MONEY
THEN LATER IN NINETEEN TWENTY
NINE THEY MOVED TO THE CITY A
PUBLIC PARK.
CLINTON ATTENDED SCHOOLS IN THE
CITIES OF BOTTOM PARKING KALINA.
IN HIS JUNIOR YEAR OF HIGH
SCHOOL HE ENLISTED IN THE
CIVILIAN CONSERVATION CORPS.
WHERE HE SERVED A SIX MONTH TOUR
IN DEATH VALLEY?
IN DECEMBER OF NINETEEN FORTY
TWO MISTER NIXON JOINED THE NAVY
AND ME FIRST CLASS AVIATION
METALSMITH.
HE SERVED AND WAS DISCHARGED
FROM THE NAVY IN DECEMBER OF
NINETEEN FORTY FIVE.
AFTER RETURNING HOME MISTER
NIXON WORKED AS A MANAGER FOR
SAFEWAY MARKETS FOR TWENTY SEVEN
YEARS.
AND WAS ALSO A SMALL BUSINESS
OWNER FOR OVER A DECADE.
MR NIXON WAS PASSIONATE ABOUT
PUBLIC SERVICE HE SERVED ON THE
VALLEY COUNTY WATER BOARD FOR
TWENTY SEVEN YEARS AND ON THE
BOTTOM PART UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT FOR TWENTY FOUR YEARS.
HE WAS ON THE REGIONAL
OCCUPATIONAL BOARD FOR FOURTEEN
YEARS AND THE PRESBYTERIAN
CHURCH BOARD FOR TWENTY YEARS.
MISTER NIXON LEAVES BEHIND HIS
WIFE OF SIXTY EIGHT YEARS FIVE
CHILDREN FOURTEEN GRANDCHILDREN
AND EIGHTEEN GREAT
GRANDCHILDREN.
AND HE IS OF VERY SPECIAL TO ME
HE SERVED ON BOTH OF THE BOARDS
THAT I SERVED ON AND WAS MY
MENTOR.
.
AND IT IS A GREAT LOSS FIVE FOR
THE CITY OF BOTTOM PART IN FOR
THE WHOLE ENTIRE COMMUNITY OF
THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
SO PLEASE JOIN ME IN A JOINING
IN THE MEMORY OF MISTER CLINT
OLIVER NIXON THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS RUBIO AND THANK
YOU MEMBERS.
MEMBERS THE QUORUM CALL REMAINS
IN PLACE
MEMBERS.
WE ARE GOING TO TAKE UP.
ITEM TWENTY FIVE.
THIS IS AB TWENTY EIGHT OH
THREE.
FILE ITEM TWENTY FIVE A. B..
TWENTY EIGHT OH THREE BY MS LIAM
ON.
THE CLERK OR RATE.
SO WE WILL TWENTY TO THREE BY
SOME WEAVERVILLE LIMON OTHERS
AND I PLAYED A PUBLIC NUISANCE.
THIS IS A LONG EMAIL. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER. AB TWENTY EIGHT
OH THREE WOULD REMOVE A
SIGNIFICANT HURDLE TO HOLDING
PAYING MANUFACTURES ACCOUNTABLE
FOR HARM CAUSED BY THEIR
PRODUCTION OF LEAD BASED PAINT.
EXPOSURE TO LED CAN SERIOUSLY
HARM A CHILD'S HEALTH EVEN A
SLIGHT ELEVATION IN BLOOD LEVELS
CAN REDUCE TAKES YOU INSTANT
ELEMENT. MILLIONS OF CHILDREN
ARE BEING EXPOSED TO LEAD IN
THEIR HOMES THROUGH AGING LEAD
BASED PAINT INCREASING THE RISK
OF DAMAGE TO THE BRAIN AND
NERVOU SYSTEM SLOWED GROWTH.
AND DEVELOPMENT AS WELL AS
LEARNING AND BEHAVIORAL
PROBLEMS.
AND HEARING AND SPEECH PROBLEMS
AS WELL.
IN TWO THOUSAND A COMPLAINT WAS
FILED IN ONE ON BEHALF OF THE
PEOPLE OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AGAINST THREE MAJOR
PAINT MANUFACTURERS THAT FOUND
THE FORMER.
A FORMER LEAD PAINT
MANUFACTURERS RESPONSIBLE FOR
PROMOTING LEAD PAINT FOR USE IN
HOMES DESPITE THEIR KNOWLEDGE
THAT THE PRODUCT WAS HIGHLY
TOXIC.
IN SPITE OF THE COURTS FOUND A
FLIGHT FINDINGS THE PAINT
MANUFACTURES ARE PROPOSING AN
INITIATIVE FOR THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN BALLOT.
THIS WOULD RELIEVE PAIN
MANUFACTURES OF LIABILITY AND DO
ACTION BY MULTIPLE COURTS AND
PUT THE SOLE FINANCIAL
RESPONSIBILITY AND CALIFORNIA
HOMEOWNERS FOR CLEANING UP LEAD
CONTAMINATED FELL.
IF ENACTED INITIATIVE WOULD COST
TAXPAYERS THREE POINT NINE
BILLION DOLLARS.
AB TWENTY TWO OR THREE WILL
ENSURE THAT THOSE AFFECTED BY
LEAD PAINT LEAD BASED PAINT ARE
ABLE TO REQUIRE.
TO RECOVER A BEAMING COST FROM
LEAD PAINT MANUFACTURERS IF
NECESSARY.
BASED ON THE JUDGMENTS OF THE
COURT THIS SEEMS TO BE A
REASONABLE PROPOSAL.
THIS BILL IS A BILL THAT WE
CONTINUE TO WORK ON AND WHEN
THIS BILL MOVES FORWARD WE ARE
HAPPY TO CONTINUE WORKING ON IT.
THANK YOU MISS THEM ON.
SAYING NO DISCUSSION.
OR DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
CLICK LIBERAL. ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
.
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO GO
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE TALLY
THE VOTES. AS FORTY ONE KNOWS
TWENTY FIVE.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS THE SESSION IS SCHEDULE
IS AS FOLLOWS.
TUESDAY MAY TWENTY SECOND CHECK
IN SESSION WEDNESDAY MAY TWENTY
THIRD CHECK IN SESSION.
THURSDAY MAY TWENTY FOUR CHECK
IN SESSION AND FLOOR SESSION
UPON CALL OF THE SPEAKER FRIDAY
MAY TWENTY FIFTH.
FLOOR SESSION IS AT NINE A. M.
ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WILL
BE PASSED TO RETAIN OUR MOTION
SHALL BE CONTINUED.
SEEN HEARING A FOR THE BUSINESS
ARE READY TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION
TO ADJOURN. MISTER LEVINE MOVES
MISTER BERMAN SECOND SET THIS
HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED.
UNTIL FRIDAY MAY TWENTY FIFTH AT
NINE AM OF THE QUORUM CALL IS
LIFTED